[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you oh my god you're sweet but we
have a [ __ ] show to do welcome to fat
meow Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Renard I feel like Bea Arthur in the
Christmas special this is awesome we've
shot an episode of fat man Batman here
but we've never done a live show this
late live show is it really yeah [ __ ]
it's weird I have to I have to organize
I'm used to like sitting and [ __ ] and
it's almost theater-in-the-round e so
you feel like you have to kind of like
we should cocktail some [ __ ] flipping
drinks oh my good bottle how much space
is there like maybe built the stage man
like that where the cantina band played
and [ __ ] like that is there a place for
the Jaycees like [ __ ] off this was hard
enough please like you want a stage and
don't say the S or the W words we're
here at scum and villainy which is an
amazing what what started as a pop-up
bar but is now a legit ongoing affair
that that JC who shoots our show has
been running for how many months now
into six it's a really cool success
story about like the bar I guess was not
it was on falling on harder times
tougher to find a clientele or whatever
and rather than just shut up shop and go
away they were like let's let's give
this a try and it looks fantastic it
gives you the general impression of like
we're in a place it's it is so close yet
not actionable so it's a good time about
it nobody has to worry that the feds are
gonna come and be like did you ever read
the warnings at the beginning of a VHS
this is theft I hurt everybody can I
this is [ __ ] awesome it the regret is
that I didn't put one of these in my
house it's never too late
how's everybody doing tonight lost this
[ __ ] lovely man we could probably get
this going at least every other week I
mean I know we haven't really started
the show but perfect size for it reminds
me of smaug castle likes mod castle
which we used to do the first podcast
here I think that ever existed the only
one that I owned was on Santa Monica
Boulevard and it fit 48 and then we put
up two more chairs so it was like a
total of 15 stuff so we can even it up
and stuff and this feels like it I think
there's about 20 more people than
SModcast here a smart castle here is
that right is this like 70 or so it's a
really good size man intimate gathering
yeah and also it's just like well I
wouldn't go that for nobody's getting
blown tonight mark but I speak for
yourself yeah good point you're
intending to do a great show you're like
I got a lot of [ __ ] thoughts they're
gonna get me blown it is it's it's a
dope space man I'm happy to be here
hopefully we could continue it it'd be
nice to do it every other week I was
thinking as I was coming I was like [ __ ]
we should have prepared trivia we'll do
that for next with JC [ __ ] Hattie you
that trivia here when was it what
tonight you just do it you just make
questions up you're like what's in my
head right now
or is it all theme to the movie room
what is there what's the prize booze
free drinks I guess in a bar that
matters I was gonna bring Star Wars toys
people like [ __ ] you bring liquor all
right man let's dive into it how are you
been doing what you've been up to I'm
doing all right fun employment is
treating me well tell us about a mark is
currently not working what's that like
it's uh that the panic hasn't set in yet
so right now it's like vacation like
vacation where I write and drink in the
afternoons so frothy drinks and
deadlines
ya know Castle Rock wrapped up just
before Labor Day and so it's been a
whirlwind of the bottled water tour of
LA and sure you've been on it where are
you going a bunch of meetings and
everybody hand you a bottle of water and
then you have for them I have four of
those this week yeah I went on four
pitches and I got four bottles water I
was like not bad but two of those
[ __ ] were in Santa Monica sighs I got
rather drink the local [ __ ] water and
not take the trip and [ __ ] was really
far right and then the problem is by
like the fifth meeting it's just a
bladder endurance test where you're just
sitting there trying to be like cool but
your bladder is like aggressively trying
to escape your body you know it's cool I
didn't tell you ideas my Star Wars but
the desert planet let's talk about the
desert man [ __ ] water wait what kind
of [ __ ] savages are these where you
can't just be like can I use your
bathroom you can do that on the way in
unless you're a little bit late cuz
there's traffic in LA so I come
screaming in as if I'm like Kip Smith
just pull it in into the meeting there's
no like taking that pee break I want out
four pitches this week and I promise you
I was late for every one of them and
like you know I realized it's no way to
get a job but like you know it's also
like I would hope the people on the
other side go well that shows a lot of
character you know what I'm like in some
weird reverse way like he you know he's
not sucking our dicks to get the job I
like the cut of his jib that's what I
tell myself but really they're just like
fat [ __ ] [ __ ] late and [ __ ] like
that but III don't I realize I don't I
don't have that like I gotta get a job
like I could do this I go out and talk
stuff like that so there's no sense
whenever I go into a room that like you
know I remember Chorus Line I really
need this job like whenever I go into
room I'll be like it's an era so there's
that song as well yeah
whenever I go in I have the luxury of
not it's not not caring but it's like
hey if this don't work it don't really
matter I went on four pitches last year
three of them [ __ ] hit one of them
didn't and the only one that I couldn't
sell was the one that I cared about the
most the one that I'd spent months
building and white boarded and had a
whole [ __ ] like AV approach to it and
stuff when I pitched it I was the mall
rat series couldn't [ __ ] find a home
for new well nobody wanted it so I wish
you ran a network but you know maybe
there's someplace in the future I can go
what's the six places and I lost hard
after all six of them were like I love
mall rats and then that was the end of
the conversation and [ __ ]
but there's still other places to go but
that's when I was like you know what
[ __ ] this why am I beat my head against
wall if I want to play with my own toys
I own Jay and Silent Bob and that's
where Jay and Silent Bob
reboot came from but the other three
pitches that I went on I had the luxury
of being like this would be fun but like
if it doesn't happen that's cool and
those were the ones that happen so I
feel like you almost have to go into
those meetings you know like [ __ ]
John bender from from Breakfast Club
like just not really given a [ __ ]
spitting up in the air and catching it
and [ __ ] and that's been though like we
got to hire this one you know I think
that's my advice to you yeah I do my
best to mop the flop sweat off my brows
and I really need this job but now okay
I write comic books I do a podcast have
you heard it I'm fine Hollywood money
I got a podcast man you could get a job
acting because I believed you for a few
seconds I was like right on he's got
healthy perspective always being
sarcastic
I just today went to the I don't know
what they call it the Burbank lot used
to be where the Jay Leno Show was shot
used to be the NBC lot not the CBS
Radford but it's just now they call it
the Burbank studio or something like
that so I was really all Jay Leno
tonight
show shot so that's where the the
Supergirl and and flash and legends and
I think it's just all of Berlanti land
is over there I've never seen arrow but
they must have a floor somewhere as well
so I've the big Salmon Ladder in the
corner yeah the like in order to get
here you got to do gross exercises and
[ __ ] I'm like I can't do that though
like you go to Supergirl so I want I
want to visit Supergirl to work on my
edit and it's weird cuz when you walk
down the hallway you walk through other
shows so I had to walk past and through
Riverdale to get to Supergirl and oddly
enough like the people that populate the
staff of Riverdale look like the kids in
Riverdale like as you walked around you
know like oh it's themed or something
but you know maybe they just inform the
show and then you get to the end of the
hallway and it's like the Supergirl
post-production suite so I went in and
did the final edit with Barbara who's
the editor of my episode they have three
different editors editors that rotate
all the episodes so I worked with
Barbara before I'm a first Supergirl
episode and I'm an editor by by trade
and heart that's what I would love to do
more than anything else they gave me my
choice like do you want to direct the
episode or edit it I would much rather
edit it but they they got people for
that sort of thing so you know when we
put the edit but she puts it together
does an assembly and [ __ ] which is weird
for me cuz usually I'm that guy that's
always hands-on but she's so good at it
it's almost a delight she sends me the
show and I get to watch it and unlike
most editors I guess sit in a room with
her and kind of walk through it scene by
scene and go oh can you move this can
you try this she'll send me a cut of the
show and then I go through it and I'll
just write down like lifts notes like
cut notes and I've never lift whole
scenes I line [ __ ] it to death I'll just
go in and pull out like this lines not
necessarily this redundant I said this
[ __ ] again you know and stuff so you
bring you take all the air out and bring
it down and bring it down so I mean I'll
sit there at home and write down the
time codes like cut from 0.16 point 12
to 0.16 point 14 you know two frames
with those [ __ ] two frames matter I'm
like I've done a good job so I did that
from home that's mostly you know got it
down to a sign
you can just send her notes takes about
three hours sit there watch the episodes
stop write all the notes and seven
probably takes him about as much time to
like cover all the notes editorially so
today was the day like the director's
cut is due where Andrew and the
higher-ups watched the episode and stuff
so I went into the office and sat down
with them and kind of went through the
episodes pretty strong episode like when
I first read the script I was like oh
nothing like nothing's really happening
in the episode that's big first episode
I did we went to [ __ ] space and
they're like this is the first time
we're going to space and we're doing it
with Kevin Smith I was a woo this time
they're like we're not going to space
conversation yeah people are going to
talk to each other I was like well I
guess that's what I'd do
so I was actually more suited for these
episodes than the space episodes but I
do people talking all the time so going
to space was novel for me like that was
cool shooting people in rubber masks
whose lasers and [ __ ] it was like
getting to do a miniature version of
Star Wars to some degree like oh this is
what it'd be like if I had Talent money
so so this time around it was more of a
thoughtful episode there's action
sequences and stuff but definitely more
of a chatty episode but it turned into
something pretty good there's some big
hallmark moments in the episode some big
things that are about to happen and
whatnot early in the season no less and
they're building their main storyline
toward their big bad rain which seems
like a [ __ ] cool storyline but I
liked the episode very much but I was
editing it at home the other day sitting
there just watching on the laptop and
then writing down cut notes and there
was the scene like that I've a moment
not even a scene it's a sequence I had a
I don't want to spoil it but it just
won't really spoil it it's at a
neighborhood pool like a recreation
center pool where kids go and stuff like
that so in the scene Melissa Benoist
Benoist however you want to say she is I
love her to death I'm not in a creepy
like leery way hey I love her because
she personifies the character like she
brings that character so richly to life
and I you know I've read comics my whole
life Supergirl was never in my [ __ ]
top 20 she
that character intellect one of my
favorite DC characters of all time like
in the right hands you know any creator
her and Andrew Kreisberg right in the
show and so turn that character's
character into somebody that I you know
deeply relate to I'm like oh my god I've
missed a whole lifetime of wonderful
Supergirl stories because character
never hit me like it does now now you
can catch up so I love her work as the
character like just as an actress but
like by the time you get to TV like
everybody's really good you know you
don't get to that place unless you've
got some serious chops generally
speaking so to say she's a really great
actress is doesn't really fully pay the
compliment absolutely [ __ ] true and
she could take weird moments and turn
them into wonderful real moments but
this is the like whenever I worked with
the three times and each time I've set a
variation of this to her like I was like
everything about you is is almost [ __ ]
perfection like I watch you deal with
everybody you know like I'm in a god
position so you see everybody watching
the monitors you got headphones on see
you hear people interact on a regular
basis don't necessarily hear you you
know what I'm saying so I watched her
for three episodes and that's the total
of ten weeks eleven weeks of the last
two years interact with people in the
cast and crew people that just come to
watch the show for shooting outside
make-a-wish kids who come to the set and
sadly there are many anybody I've seen
her interact with she's he treats them
all the same equally wonderful she can
give a [ __ ] if you're the director or
you're Antichrist Burt or if you're just
some dude who was like oh my god I watch
the show all the time when they're
shooting in the park she she engages
with them she's really [ __ ] sweet with
them she looks and listens like it's not
just like hey man you're great and then
she walks away you know for that moment
you're talking to her she's fully
engaged with you so I you know I was
tell her I was like look the acting
thing we all know you're great at this
[ __ ] I said but like you've got the
human [ __ ] down to a science like in a
way that most people in this business
I was like just your you were raised
well and you were crushing it like never
lose that it's one of your most
endearing qualities and you'll work
forever with that she's the number one
on the show so that means she's there
all the [ __ ] time shows called
Supergirl you could shoot every one of
the other characters in the head still
have a [ __ ] show as long as she's
there so like she's in nearly every
scene and her workload is like if they
shoot eight day weeks with one day of
green-screen she works all eight and
then on the green-screen day and never
seen her [ __ ] never seen her be like
come on let's [ __ ] hurry up and [ __ ]
like he'd go late into the evening and
[ __ ] she's just like what are we doing
next always so [ __ ] Pleasant [ __ ] so
I like her a lot and I'm watching this
moment where I'm cutting you know on my
laptop and she's at this pool and it's a
real [ __ ] throwaway moment she has to
say and I'm trying to do it without
spoiling and [ __ ]
but her line is she has to call win and
at the de oh and she has to say it's
very exposed Tori line like because
we're in a pool and we've seen her do it
and she looks at the water and she's
like I'm gonna take a sample and so so
she has a little device that she can
hook up to her cell phone so she goes
cause win first and she goes when I'm
gonna send you a sample from a public
pool it was one of the most exposed Tory
lines in the [ __ ] script but that
line alone she made it seem like she
just came up with it like right off the
spot all the best acting makes people
that was when actors and actors make it
seem like they just thought of that [ __ ]
right then and there like not that I've
got a prepared speech that they're like
everyone else that like you hear
somebody and you react you know acting
is a lot of reacting in [ __ ] so she took
this nothing line and [ __ ] like
rocked it where you know as a guy who's
like looking for lines to cut you know
when I'm gonna send you a sample from
the public pool when we know she's doing
it we're seeing her do it it's redundant
you can get away with cutting it and in
a world where you're trying to get an
episode down to 41 minutes from 55 to 41
every little bit counts
but her [ __ ] delivery was so [ __ ]
realistic and so good I was like I'm
gonna let it ride for now and then the
next thing she does is takes this dopey
little device to the prop Department
bill dips in the pool
and then shoves it into her iPhone and
that is then communicating the info to
win you know it's science fiction and
unless I think Apple 10 could do this
[ __ ] I don't know and you know and then
the scene goes on from there so in the
in that moment even in the [ __ ] like
I'm attaching this thing to the phone
she like found a way to like make it
work she the crinkles her brow it's like
you know she's not like just doing it
smoothly she's doing it like a person
who has been handed these two things
that have never had to do this before
would do it it's [ __ ] spellbinding
it's the little things acting is not
about like look at how many words I know
it's selling dopey [ __ ] like that so I
fell in love with this moment man and
like I know her you know she's dating
Chris Wood the guy who played mono last
year so I [ __ ] sent him a text
because I didn't want to text her in the
middle of the it was 5:00 in the morning
and I've got to be weird to be like I'm
looking at you you know [ __ ] creepy
but he and I share an affinity for her
as an actress and as a person and [ __ ]
like when we talk we generally one of
the topics conversation is like is she
great you know we just sit around and
blow her even though she's not there so
I blew him up man I start texting him
and I sent him like a little screen grab
it's like five seconds of that [ __ ]
moment and I said do me a favor watch
this and I shot it with my phone off my
laptop and sent it to him and then wrote
like four paragraphs I'll just [ __ ]
read it too because it was so [ __ ]
like embarrassing later on I felt like
why did I do that but when you're a
STONER you know you just want to share
with everybody in check so I wrote this
is what I wrote to my row at 5:40 in the
morning so I'm editing my Supergirl app
right now and Melissa is great
throughout but I just want to call your
attention to this quiet moment of genius
and I put that clip and I wrote the
public pool line is crazy expository but
that girl of yours makes it a tiny meal
like I believe she's having that convo
on the phone
and look at how she crinkles her brow
while clicking the device into place I
said that [ __ ] deserves an award I'm
only halfway through mind you this was
five seconds of material I said I could
watch excellence all day that is
excellent it's not the big showy stuff
it's taken chuffa and making it real
[ __ ] like this makes me appreciate the
mad skills this lady jedi wheels and
it's holding me over until we get to the
and then I spoil some stuff talking
about a storyline I can't tell you that
and I can't tell get in trouble and then
I said [ __ ] I love this show I said
anyway you're the only one I could talk
to about this spoilers and [ __ ] hope
Europe was fun and so so when does the
restraining order
the old man sending text a boyfriend I'm
like we're contemporaries but they're
their [ __ ] 20s this kid must begin to
text at 5 in the morning go
oh [ __ ] why did I give him our number
you know so I send those texts and I go
back to editing and I swear after three
minutes I checked my phone going like
can't believe it and text me back yet
then he finally texts me back like hours
later like he wrote a Jedi she maybe if
confer ting converting babble into magic
isn't using the force then I don't know
what is and he goes I think I've watched
those five seconds thirty seven times
now for your good measure it really is
very impressive I don't know how she
does it like we get into a mutual fan
club if we creepy like two two [ __ ]
dudes talking about this woman like that
well one of us is right next to and [ __ ]
like that and we're all going isn't she
great I don't know it's kind of sweet
it's the one of the rare like joys of
being in this in this
business is like and doing [ __ ] like
that like I love working on Supergirl
they really don't [ __ ] need me at all
I've talked about this a million times
in the most recent visit it was never
more painfully clear how [ __ ] useless
I am up there then it than it was this
time around just and that's not because
I like I'm a [ __ ] idiot or something
although who I am it has everything to
do with they make that show every
[ __ ] week without me and periodically
I pop up and I'm like I'm ready to
tackle Supergirl with you guys and like
yeah it's real hard you know cuz they do
it all the [ __ ] time and if I can't
try to come up with [ __ ] I'm like I got
an idea for a shot in here we come
through here and we'll go through here
and they're like yeah we did that two
episodes ago but let's do it again you
know so it's tough to like find new
ground to break there it's tough to
really justify why you're there at all
they've in my personal opinion when
you've got like after year one of a show
when you got like a season under your
belt everybody knows what the [ __ ]
going on and [ __ ] you really don't need
an episodic director I know like the
directors guilds like [ __ ] but it's kind
of true you really don't I've been on
five of these shows and I every time I'm
like hum do anything and the guy who's
the runs the DT Sankey he runs the video
like correction system like when they're
shooting right there on the DI T right
there on set used to be a whole separate
job they're doing post now they do it
like as they're shooting it's [ __ ]
incredible so he's like you know I hear
you say a lot that you don't do anything
except buy food that's my thing that's
how I direct that show I bring food and
give everybody food I'm like here's some
Timbits like you're a great director I'm
like they taught me this in film school
about food so so you know I I said like
I've said many times like [ __ ] I really
don't feel like I have the place here
like I love being around this [ __ ] I
love seeing the show come together and
reading the script early and seen
episodes early but like you guys got
this Seamus the DP is a [ __ ] genius
he shot this show so many [ __ ] times
he could do it in his [ __ ] sleep
right and the actors and actresses they
all know what they're doing there's
nothing I can't be like hey man take it
from the guy who made tough this is how
you want to play you know like they know
what they're doing they know their
characters inside and out and stuff like
that
so I'm never quite sure like what my
[ __ ] role in that world
is other than to be like super
supportive and enthusiastic and stuff
and you know I go cuz it's fun to be
there and stuff but at the same time I
feel like you know like this time around
I was up there and I saw my friend Carol
banker you know banker one of my
favorite people in the world she is a
script supervisor on Mallrats
knock-knock clerks Mallrats not chasing
amy but Dogma and then after Dogma we
did Jay and Silent Bob strike back she
was on no she wasn't on that then she
was Jersey girl oh my god she's the Star
Trek of [ __ ] you know continuity kid
she does every other one the good ones
entry like me so I used to work with her
a lot back in the day Dogma especially
like I remember this moment on Dogma she
wanted to be a director nobody wants to
be a script supervisor it's usually on
your way to something else so she'd
always wanted to direct and you know
it's tough for her to find a place to
break in like she worked on The X Files
for years when I moved to Los Angeles so
she got to direct a lone gunman but then
the x-files stopped so she didn't get to
do any of those so recently in the last
like two three years good time for
diversity in the business now it's like
they're like look we can't keep hiring
[ __ ] middle-aged white guys to do
this [ __ ] there are other people that do
this [ __ ] as well and so whom like
suddenly you're seeing a lot more people
on sets that then you saw before that
like oh [ __ ] here's a new perspective
and one that's beautiful so Carol is one
of those people she's working a [ __ ] ton
now and she was up in Vancouver we were
shooting the scene outside and I was in
this little tent that's where the
monitors weren't stuff and all sudden
she comes in out of nowhere I haven't
seen her in a couple years and I'm I'm
Holly [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] are you
doing here she's like I'm directing an
episode of The Magicians and so we were
scouting in town and I saw Supergirl and
I was like his [ __ ] Kevin Smith there
and they're like he is and she's like so
I [ __ ] trucked over and so I was like
oh my god I was a and we were
chit-chatting about work and the
magician's it's like her second episode
so it's like well you got do one of
these man if I could make more sense you
make a super girl than me what the [ __ ]
people do I know about [ __ ] being a
girl in 47 year old man and [ __ ] like
that year you bring something to this
and Carol goes well I met with the
people at Warner Brothers last year
people who you know
the I don't know what the job is but the
people that put directors onto those
shows she's like and we had a great
meeting and they said we're gonna put
you on an episode of Supergirl we have
an episode of Supergirl coming up we
think you'd be great for and she was
like all perfect and so the next week
her agent called her and was like yeah
you're not gonna get that episode of
Supergirl and she was like why the [ __ ]
not did they give it to some [ __ ]
white man it goes yeah Kevin Smith so so
I was like no [ __ ] way she's like
yeah he took my Supergirl and I was like
aw [ __ ] me I'm sorry I had no idea so I
love going up there but I also feel like
you know in a world where I'm like I
don't do anything Carol banker wouldn't
say that she'd be like I did everything
and [ __ ] like that and so I feel like I
shouldn't try to hog up episodes you
know what I'm saying like right when I
left I don't think I was scheduled to do
another Supergirl this year but they
were all like dude find a way to come
back I was like it ain't about me
the slots are booked if somebody drops
out that's how I got to do to last year
maybe somebody can't do it in the second
half so I'll get one of those apps but I
said I really if one opens up like I
should like push Carol for it or anybody
else you know it's not like I'm I love
it I [ __ ] love it so much but I've
done it and when I do it I come out and
go like yeah they don't need me and you
know that's somebody else wouldn't have
that perspective somebody else would be
like well maybe you don't [ __ ] try or
something maybe I'd like to take the
opportunity to try and bring something
to it and stuff but they'd like me to
come back the cast and the crew because
this guy Schanke he said I hear you talk
about how you suck at this and you just
buy people food he goes which is true
you do buy people food and stuff he's
gone but like I'll be honest with you I
I'm in a seat where I sit in front of a
lot of directors every director of the
show comes through here so I've sat in
front of a bunch of people and the only
difference between you and every other
person that sits in that chair is when
you're here everybody's [ __ ] happy
and I was like really and he said yeah
and I was like but does that count as
directing it goes
he goes what do you care you know that
was a good point ma'am so it's I love I
love doing it but one of the things the
byproduct the thing that I really dig is
I'm fan first firs ever [ __ ] filmmaker
I just love this [ __ ]
so I get to fan out with a [ __ ]
in the show you know what I'm saying
like I could be just talking to my
friend online go on [ __ ] I love
Supergirl in this weird moment where she
[ __ ] check the pool is like
hysterical to me but instead I get to go
right to a dude who's like uh oh I know
man like and I'll tell her you know she
had like that where I'm like oh that's
[ __ ] cool so the episode turned out
good I think people are gonna I think
people are gonna dig it and then I have
a flash coming up in January I go back
up and do my third flash knock would ya
unless they [ __ ] throw me off or
something like could happen
directors getting fired left and right
in the town these days man that should
lead us right into the news shouldn't it
yeah there's there was an open
director's job that went to middle-aged
white guy yeah Colin Trevorrow got fired
from episode 9 oh my god what will they
do they well they will hire a dude who
looks like him but older does he does he
look like Kyle Traverse a white dude
yeah are you saying we all look alike
like a corona and a half maybe
I know JJ Abrams is stepping into direct
episode yes I'm a big fan of this idea
when we were throwing around names about
people to do I don't even know if we
said JJ because I thought he was like
one and done I did it I'm dropping the
mic y'all have some my name's Paul's
between y'all and [ __ ] so I don't think
he was even up for consideration but
apparently he was yeah probably right
Johnson was up first did they go to him
first went to him and he begged off
because you know he just spent two years
making the Star Wars movie and he seems
to be like I want to make my stuff like
I did this was fun I would agree with
God time to go back and make my [ __ ] I
interviewed him once on smoothie makers
the podcast we do and he was a real real
good guy like honest to god good guy
like the vibe I got from him and stuff
and and the [ __ ] he said made a lot of
sense Mona but that's my impression like
you know oh my god I'm gonna do a Star
Wars this would be amazing but he's a
storyteller I think he's got stories of
his own to tell but that's crazy you
know kind of character chose to be like
now I'm not gonna take the second like
Star Wars Episode II those millions of
dollars or yeah are just like to be able
to push back from the table like that
clearly I've you know always had a
problem pushing back from the [ __ ]
table but this is a guy who's just like
no man I did it it was a sumptuous
banquet I never thought I'd do that it
happened it's great I'm gonna I'm good
and now now I'm gonna go back to my
stuff good for him yeah so JJ stepping
in there pushing the release date back
from May 2019 to December 2019 a bit
Jezza JJ choice he's just like last time
we won a Christmas next time we go at
Christmas JJ metal like that
mmm can't tell you something that's
lucky so I'll see if it's funny if it's
not funny then I can lose it so we're
making this movie called Jay and Silent
Bob reboot and this is something like a
I'm gonna say something this will be a
cut point for everybody else at home
this is just for the folks in the room
you know I turn the camera off just
saying like down the road when we edit
it
yeah we're back
back into the show okay so JJ now in
charge of Star Wars again absolute smart
choice I know some people online will
like all come on but I
this is dude who [ __ ] kicked open the
doors the franchise again and I know a
lot of people like all he did was do
[ __ ] Star Wars over but that's not a
that's not true but be that was kind of
the [ __ ] point was to mirror that
experience and the movie is not a beat
for beat remake of [ __ ] stars I've
seen people be like great this is gonna
be a b4b remake of Return of the Jedi
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] first force awakens is not
a be for beat remake of Star Wars
it is a mirror to how you felt when you
saw that first movie it's you know some
people have accused of being a fan film
I don't think that's insult I think
that's absolutely true that movie was
made with love and affection by some of
they love the first movie and said I
want to communicate that same experience
to the next generation so I've never
thought it was a copy I felt it was I
thought it was a worthy reboot the force
awakens had an impossible task to
achieve yes target was so [ __ ] small
like womp rat neo t16 back home it is
you have to make a movie make a movie
that appealed to us yeah at first we had
to make a movie that introduced new
people to the entire saga yeah you had
to give the the the sort of nostalgic
vibe to it
throw the story forward it had to be a
nostalgic and advancing and resonant and
evocative and all of that [ __ ] once it's
an a simple thing to do and he did it
and he pulled it off and the movie made
like a [ __ ] ton of money to like and
they did it in a schedule with the
window and you know some people listen
to like hey man it's not like curing
cancer of course none of this shit's
like curing cancer but in terms of
hitting a [ __ ] release date and
hitting expectations maybe exceeding
expectations giving everyone the Star
Wars movie that they were kind of hoping
for particularly when like the previous
three let everybody [ __ ] him down it was
a it was a miracle a miracle act and he
[ __ ] did it so the fact that like he
stepped away from it I always thought
was kind of dope I was like right on man
drop the mic you're [ __ ] finished you
got nothing to prove because you just
proves it all but I think it's smart to
go back to
in a world were clearly Cathy Kennedy is
like I don't I don't like what I'm tired
of rolling the dice and these
[ __ ] yeah it's like this is a
guy I know and I know what he does and
any [ __ ] crushed it so let's turn to
him I think it was a smart choice man
I'm glad he's doing it it means I might
get to be a stormtrooper again see they
got moving for two black dudes and Star
Trek Star Wars maybe yeah jinx brother
Feifei yeah man [ __ ] it's good news
what did you hear when it dropped what
were what was the word I mean most of
the word online that I said was both
like yeah JJ and the opportunity to
broaden the field of directors true to
invite more people to play in that
particular you know playground is a
wasted one to a certain degree JJ will
absolutely crush it he will deliver a
movie that people will love but being
able to get sort of diversity of
plurality of opinion to what Star Wars
is and can be it's still out there and
it's still kind of magnetic at least for
me to see what Star Wars looks like
through somebody else's eyes good news
is it doesn't seem like they're stopping
this [ __ ] anytime soon seems like every
week they're like here's another one
young Han Solo young Boba Fett young
Yoda I would like to see young Yoda
actually I would like to see all of them
there's not a single thing I've heard so
far that I'm like I'm against this I
know some people get kind of shitty
about it like oh they're just [ __ ]
churning money out of this well of
course they spent four billion dollars
to buy it they weren't [ __ ] bagging
and boarding it and putting on their
wall it was about like we're gonna turn
this into a marketable franchise again
and as a fan of the earlier stuff or all
the stuff just delighted that they're
like hey we're gonna tell more first I
was a little irritated by the other day
I was like well nine Episode nine that's
the last Saga movie and somebody was
like why do you think that
and I was like because George Lucas said
it oh [ __ ]
and I you know you realize like we're
gonna one day they're gonna announce
here comes episode 10 11 12 and we will
be the end of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we will never see the end of
the Star Wars Cinematic Universe good
and I'm happy with that honestly
unlike the only way I'd be okay with it
ending if I was like I'm dying and
they're like we're gonna end this [ __ ]
for you keV you know that way when I
died I'd have to worry about what I was
fear of missing out is a big thing for
me and sure like that so I could see the
end of this up it would laddie yeah
that's true about take that before tea
yeah and that haunts him afterwards you
lying pricks
unless the movies were good then I'd be
like why didn't you do this but it was a
lot all right so JJ back on Star Wars
great [ __ ] news the ship is righted
moving forward what else we got
the news broke today that according to
Roald Dahl's Widow hmm
Charlie Bucket from Charlie in the
chocolate factory was initially supposed
to be a black kid is that right yeah
there's original formulation for the
story why do I in my head I have him
tied in with racism but it's more
anti-semitism is that right yeah he
didn't like some people for sure but it
wasn't black people apparently
and I think he's thinking was that in
the sixties in London there was a
massive workforce of you can't call them
african-americans because it's London so
black people who are working in
factories you know and who were [ __ ]
poor and on the dole and living my
people to a house like why couldn't that
be that would make sense yeah yeah what
happened his agent argued him against
his vocation is book age said that the
the audience might not accept a young
black hero racist to say the least I was
trying to think is there any there's no
diversity in that cast whatsoever right
there's a blue lady that's right when
she would violet turns viola viola
that's that's the one skin color you get
and no bloopers like green people from
wherever probably we're gonna be African
pygmies but that's okay that's cool
so yeah wow what a different story that
would have been altogether let me let me
ask you this let's say he sticks with it
we're stuck with it and Charlie Bucket
was a black kid would the movie have
kept that or would the movie have made
him a white kid you think what year was
the movie made 1970 okay so do you think
they would have whitewashed I mean is a
ridiculous conversation because it's all
sci-fi at this point like what would
have happened mark and put a Dewback in
it what what do you think do you think I
would have gotten away with it or no I
think he would have been a white kid in
that movie but like this broke today on
Twitter and Ava Duvernay
like raise their hand said I'd know how
to make this [ __ ] movie let me do it
Ava who seems to be now the champion
Godhead of all things diversity
yeah [ __ ] I'll do it what do you got
wrinkle in time make this a black girl
what do you got Willy Wonka black dude
yeah why not like and now there's like
historical precedent for it especially
if like his widows like knows what he
wanted back in the day would Tim Burton
do it no I believe I believe we've seen
that he's never made a black person
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the floor is yours where do you want to
go now Game of Thrones is gonna be like
fantasy cloob Game of Thrones why
because they're gonna shoot multiple
endings to the season is that it's all
an effort to - for piracy oh it's just
about piracy it's not like depending in
which time zone you live
Cersei wins in this way
no but yeah so they're gonna shoot like
three or four different endings I would
[ __ ] take all of them honestly
[ __ ] yeah yeah there's like no bad to
that it's like oh man I'm with the one
true ending I'm like [ __ ] I don't want
it to end so keep it going give me 19
endings and [ __ ] make that [ __ ] like
Lord of the Rings we're just never
stopped just kept [ __ ] going alright
so the idea is they don't want us to
know for sure right until the day of
area so that when crazy [ __ ] pirates
stealing on the internet they don't know
which one they're stealing which is when
when is that they have been given a date
yet that they they say next year they
say 2018 the last six episodes will drop
six plus because now there's 14 endings
it's the only reason to stay alive that
long listen I get Black Panther in the
spring so we all get yeah all right what
else we got it good doing insanely well
right down the street there is some sort
of interactive exhibit I drove past the
other day
what is it the that the well how's that
what they call what
Neeb old house that's what it called it
in the book in the movie nibbled Nemo
they built a version of that like a
block from here and I saw a long line
going down the street and I was like I
usually and whenever I see a long line
in Los Angeles I'm like what is it some
event is that a live show a sneaker
store there's usually like a
some like sneakers being introduced and
there's a huge [ __ ] line so I assumed
it was sneaker store but then also and I
saw the creepy tree in the building do
you have to pay to go in it no three of
mansions were like booked solid I think
it might be closed that it only did it
for a minute I mean they only get it
before open cuz it's [ __ ] PR selling
stuff I know but why not like if people
are into it why not just [ __ ] let it
keep going should and charge rent I'm
sure so anyway what about it made some
money made all the money in one hundred
and twenty three million dollars in its
opening weekend
yeah I'll choose the highest-grossing
horror movie the highest opening horror
movie of all time I was all right
biggest September opening of all time
and also made another 118 million
worldwide I think I spoke with fin
wolfhard
fin plays Richie in the movie and he was
spent like he's the highlight of the
movie the kids hysterical and it's not
just like Oh kids cursing or funny but
they are and he was great in it he's the
kid who plays Mike and stranger things
he's going lovey-lovey dude I met him on
the IMDB boat and interviewed him and
stuff like that and so German Interview
magazine remember the interview magazine
I don't think they published it here
anymore back in the day interview
magazine used to have people interview
each other they wouldn't have a
journalist to it they would be like you
interview this person stuff the guy did
did I do that for I forget who I
interviewed for interview but you know
he usually called them on the phone or
something like that so they were it's
German interview magazines still
publishes and they were like yeah off in
Avadh requested you so I was like really
you know like yeah he likes you quite a
bit so we did the interview interview
like the day after the movie opened huge
so it was the Monday so I was like oh my
god dude what is it like to be in like
the pop cultural phenomenon of the
streaming world that captured
everybody's imagination here and now to
be in a [ __ ] movie that has like
become this huge and captured
everybody's imagination like when you
stand at the crossroads of
all things pop culture like what do you
what is your Monday look like and he's
like I'm in school what a good kid man I
said what a [ __ ] I said with a name
like Finn wolf hard you should be on
Game of Thrones and not as an actor as a
character like Lord Finn wolf hard and
[ __ ] like that really nice kid but he
crushed in that movie he was wonderful
movie you haven't seen it yet no you
think you think you'd be afraid of it I
am mortified of horror
so really I'm probably gonna recruit
some friends to come in old my hand as I
go I am I mean I mean that this is not
putting the movie down in any way shape
or form but like if you saw the
miniseries you [ __ ] fine there's one
or two things that'll only [ __ ] that's a
new spin but it's the same story they
don't really change much you know
there's a clown in the sewer and he's
pretty shitty spoilers it's just but
it's it's it's kind of like I mean I
don't know how else to say it's kind of
like the book and kind of like the
miniseries but they just did it in a
movie theater and it's a great movie
going experience and it's cool because
it allows them to like do this movies as
a standalone and then to see coil eyes
it and we'll all be interested in the
sequel because already we're parently
we're interested in the first one but
now we got the fun game of gone okay
who's gonna play who who are they gonna
cast to be this person it's stuff like
that I guess we could do it we could
play a little bit right here but you
haven't seen that look alright so Finn
plays Ritchie who would be the adult
Ritchie Charlie Day what a great [ __ ]
who said that excellent [ __ ] choice
you should be in casting it was awesome
is right off the top of your head great
[ __ ] pic that's real good
alright let's do the rest who could be
Beth still in [ __ ] pig man she might
and this is not an insult but she might
like the character has to be how old
they said 27 years from now and the kids
were that might actually work out that
would work man
fucking-a alright what about the fat kid
kept Smith please say yes Chris Pratt
does he in the book and the miniseries
does he get thin when he gets older so
it could [ __ ] be Chris Pratt Chris
Pratt did don't remind me you like Chris
Pratt got skinny what's your Excuse you
look at thank you all right so what
about the hypochondriac kid [ __ ] that's
two for two man I like your fantasy
football league and then who's left the
main character bill which one was Mike
Mulligan free [ __ ] 73 years old
[Applause]
Jordan Peele wow man Wow good Paul was
that you again you're gonna have to join
us on the show soon man is that
everybody know who plays bill a stutter
okay michael fassbender that's a good
fall I wonder if he'd do it I like it
man Gyllenhaal
I just watched Oscar Isaac I just
watched life last night
there's a 99 cent rental on iTunes so
that good that good it was basically it
was a lien which you know I'm down with
that but it's true I guess yeah this one
was alien with a flower it kind of what
it looked like it looked like a flower
and it jumped in people's mouths and
[ __ ] like that
like at one point spoiler it's like it
climbs into Ryan Reynolds mouth and the
whole time I'm like just bite down dick
instead he's like oh [ __ ] you to death
yeah
that'd be my version um all right so
what do we wear we go after this did you
have anything else to say about it
the only got to say about it is that
bill skarsgård he's in Castle Rock like
he plays a mysterious character
everybody's mysterious that's what the
[ __ ] bad robot lions everything he's
in that your show the castle Ron
generally cats walk so he came to the
office for for lunch before he wanted to
set and like a lovely dude like a little
bit like vacant like that handsome you
don't have to be witty when you look
like a vacant Swedish supermodel what a
godly backwards compliment man he's so
attractive he could be boring and he was
really nice and but still didn't quite
his brother is the one from True Blood
right yeah I would suck that guy's dick
give a [ __ ] man right in front of my
wife I wouldn't care I feel like you
understand yeah man as they're both
stellan skarsgård kid a guy's got some
[ __ ] good-looking sperm he does he's
got two beautiful kids both of those
kids are gonna learn most hens words and
yeah that's right they're Hema worthy
that was worthy thank you all right
where do we go after this I think you
gotta bring it down to me Lynne Wien Oh
Len one great Len Wein passed away
ladies gentlemen
and those are applause or for his life's
work not for his death Len Wein if you
don't know the man and I say why do you
say we know is there a doesn't Wayne
Wayne no wasn't Len of course without
Len you don't have Wolverine co-creator
of Wolverine without Len you don't get
the Swamp Thing co-creator of Swamp
Thing we lost both swampthing creators
in the span of what six months Bernie
Wrightson died not too long ago now lens
gone as well without Lainey you don't
get watch me he was the editor right
yeah absolute legend I met him once at a
con and he was a super nice guy he knew
I was a massive Swamp Thing fan as well
he worked on some great Batman stories
as well as even if if you're doing a
Mount Rushmore of comic book creators a
particularly of the 70s he might
actually wind up right right up and if
you would I think the the sheer tonnage
of the work that he did is a second only
maybe to stand in me I'm giving the
world characters they didn't have before
I'm giving you mythos as you never saw
before you know and with Wolverine first
and foremost we don't live in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that we do today
without Wolverine know so they're right
it's true I mean yes blade yes Superman
yes all those things but it showed that
a Marvel character was viable - you mean
people don't remember now it's we live
in a Marvel world but you know one point
they were like hey the Punisher he's got
a skull on his knife kids that's I swear
he's the Punisher it's Dolph Lundgren
Marvel couldn't like get it together
Marvel no Marvel movie ever really
worked because they were bankrupt and so
until blade that was the first one all
the sudden people were like Halle sure
there's a cool last concept except the
blade the thing my blade was the blade
was a horror movie that you had to know
it was a comic book first it was not a
superhero movie at all yeah the x-men is
a superhuman very German is undeniably
about superheroes and so without that
movie you don't get spider-man and
without spider-man you don't get
everything we're living in now and so
yeah in a very real way in a religion
way modern superhero cinema rests on the
back of Len we Wow so wish we had gotten
to say that too
while I was here I met him at a
convention once I was on a panel with
him and Chris Claremont my god [ __ ]
legends and she what were you doing
there basically referring the two of
them because they were like big dick
measuring contest between them because
Chris Claremont would like I wrote the
next one for 18 years and Len would say
what did you write B oh yeah you wrote
Wolverine and storm and I made those
guys up all right what would you do if I
didn't make those guys up and person
well I'd rather excellent woods nobody
give a [ __ ] it was an hour of the two of
them just battering each other with
their giant [ __ ] which was interesting
as a road men so wrinkly what a great
eulogy for the great Len was how I roll
he had a wrinkly dick said Mark Bernardo
absolute [ __ ] legend Swamp Thing one
of my favorite characters and something
they've done movies on Swamp Thing in
the past of the first one directed by
the great Wes Craven I don't know who
directed the second one but the second
one was a lot closer to the Alan Moore
stuff that I was so into he actually
looked like him and they did what's her
name Heather Locklear played Abby arcane
so they actually kind of got a little
closer to the books but that is a
concept that could totally be done as a
flick I know they've talked about doing
Justice League dark with Swamp Thing as
one of the characters and Guillermo
directing but apparently he's off it now
but I think they could that character
could stand alone he doesn't need to be
part of team you could totally make a
Swamp Thing movie especially now it's
like everybody's kind of you know about
saving the environment [ __ ] that ties in
directly with it
superhero is kind of for the green all
that all the [ __ ] that character was
about you could definitely make play and
a flick or an ongoing series I hope I
hope they do that soon and not just
leave them to like yeah it'll be good if
we ever get around to Justice League
Darts a viable character yeah they
should work on two quick hits yeah patty
Jenkins the final in lockdown as the
director
right on that was probably the biggest
non surprise news of the week right
there it was so good yeah some strange
that for a while is like they still
haven't locked her up yet it's like what
are you [ __ ] crazy she's the one that
works would you [ __ ] bring her back
please
so boom she's back and and she gets to
write it as well as they said develop
the story at least and she brought on a
co-writer from The Expendables for some
reason I don't know but alright sure yes
whatever look she did such a great job
of the first movie I'll trust her if she
wants to bring [ __ ] Stallone on to
play Wonder Woman I'll trust her and
[ __ ]
I believe in her um that's good but I've
read something I didn't read the article
but I saw headline about it she get paid
a lot of money what is it a getting paid
nine million she's gonna get [ __ ] he's
pretty good give me that she got 1
million for the first one but that's
about what Zack got paid for Man of
Steel so well he had done to be fair he
had what 300 he had 300 which made them
a lot of [ __ ] money yes sucker-punch
which made them no money right Annie had
Donna the dead which was really actually
very good maybe it's best movie ever
I'm not care who you are 1 million to 9
million is a massive [ __ ] right that
is all the millions it's all but yeah
I'm sure look I'm and plus I'm sure he's
got like profit participations that the
movie does as big as the last one does
she'll get it was part of the
renegotiation was give me a big chunk
back in good for her
I mean honestly like she's made the
difference that movie is wonderful I
just re-watched it you know it's on
iTunes and [ __ ] so I rewatched again
[ __ ] Amazonians I don't they never
really say that the thigh mysterion's
jumping off the [ __ ] cliff with bows
and arrows
it's a beautiful [ __ ] heroic image
and when you go to comic book movies
like you know every once in a while you
you forget that like the splash page is
where the comic book movie is born it's
not so much the little panels but like
oh my god look at this gorgeous [ __ ]
rendering that crosses the [ __ ]
Staples this is amazing and those movies
tend to have those moments you see them
in the trailers that's what they sell
them on that moment like I don't know if
they realized how like
like it was you know I'm sure I was sat
between two women watching that movie my
daughter I'm oh right and my wife on my
left and that moment happened and I
[ __ ] Duggars eyes that looks metal a
[ __ ] right and I look at them and
they're bawling just bawling because
they're like I've never seen a woman do
these things you've your whole life
you've seen men jumping around doing
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] like this is my moment
shut the [ __ ] up Kevin you know so I was
like I just want to say it look cool but
[ __ ] like that give her all the money
man that's what made people want to go
in the first place and that movie held
together considering you can see the
outside influence of like you know it's
got a third act that's right out of a
Zack Snyder movie where [ __ ] gets dark
and explodey and whatnot ignored in this
guy there's a lot of floating garbage
but still like it it didn't lose me I
wasn't like all [ __ ] it's just a Suicide
Squad and it held together like of
course she's got a barrel at battle
Harry's it was cool that it was him and
didn't see that necessarily coming in
[ __ ] so I look forward to seeing what
she does with the next one in a big bad
way truly she's now on it
and and given DC SiC credibility that
they have not had until this [ __ ]
moment in time and they're gonna spend
it on Shazam
so what's after that last thing is I saw
the Inhumans the two-part IMAX I went to
the feet I paid [ __ ] money holy [ __ ]
job so I spent like real money to go
through the Union so wait a second see
you saw it an IMAX theater how much did
it cost the normal price of going on
movie well like a Tuesday morning so not
only did I spent half price
I had a theater to myself it's like you
went to see Kevin Smith movie Hey
a lot of room fine oh yeah I take my
shoes off what about another seat just
cuz you expect that of a yo goes there's
not of a Marvel thing not so much room
or with it it is uh go ahead over here
let's hold on yeah before before it
sounds like it's gonna be a pile on
before we full do that how is how is
Kilowog no that's not Kilowog how is
lockjaw lockjaw sorry oh my god I went
to a different [ __ ] universe
altogether Lantern is adorably CGI in
normal how much more of them in the show
is there compared to the trailer elected
the trailer I have all the lockjaw
what is it there's a decent let Ilana
okay you know uses like bad
teleportation GPS but whatever that's
fine
okay I will I will spoil something for
you which will explain exactly why this
is so shitty way it has this aired yet
no no it doesn't air until next week
next week I it so big-time spoilers if
you're long three two one take us there
Medusa her only power the only reason
what she's cool
this is you have this long red hair that
she could wield prehensile II yes like
just [ __ ] come through here and we've
seen in the ads we're not the ads but
the the first piece of art they put out
she has red hair but it looked like a
wig right and then the first trailer
they put out didn't show active hair a
second trailer showed some CG hair that
can pick people up and ship right so
it's basically connect just just like
thinking real hard and CG making hair do
[ __ ] that is the only reason she's
interesting that's her thing that's her
[ __ ] thing it would be like if you
were I don't I am fisting you never use
the iron fist i watch that many serious
yeah
not so much I'm fisting so Medusa the
only reason she's cool [ __ ] here
halfway through the the two-hour pilot
yes
spoilers again for everybody they cut
her hair so are you [ __ ] serious yeah
because it's the it's the the [ __ ]
Ramsay Bolton dick move is like I'm
taking over
[ __ ] Adeline and black both is gonna
be deposed and [ __ ] you I got these
shears because he's got like [ __ ]
like barbershop shears on the moon
because that's what you do and he
decides to like [ __ ] it this is my dick
move I'm shaving your hair halfway
through the halfway through the pilot
the one interesting thing about this
character is gone now clearly the reason
to do that is it's too much money we
can't afford the CG yeah that's that's
literally the only mean of course you
can make the argument hey it's a story
point blah blah blah but if you gave a
[ __ ] about her well you saw her do a
bunch of cool [ __ ] with that hair and
this was bringing her low this was her
her heroic and made deer instead its
route of money we gotta pay for that
[ __ ] dog so sorry about your hair
lady and so for the rest of the pilot
she's just like Sinead O'Connor just
rolling around Hawaii where the [ __ ]
buzz cut looking sad because she has no
hair I mean I get it like I get like
when we did red state I'd written an
ending for red state that was literally
the apocalypse angels calm people's
heads explode and [ __ ] like that thank
you but we couldn't do it like we had a
four million dollar budget and it's like
I can't do that ending so I wrote an
ending where it's like looking like it's
about to happen and then somebody tells
you oh it didn't really happen there are
some kids [ __ ] around so we get to
have our cake and eat it too a little
bit but we didn't get to do the big
expensive thing so I had to find a fix
that was the fix sounds like their fix
was like we can't afford to [ __ ]
spend you know two hundred thousand
three hundred thousand alone on the hair
because that's what it would be like the
budgets on these shows I would say on
something like that
your effects budget tops tops million
bucks and that's being super generous on
an
along so you know a bunch of that maybe
a hundred thousand or more would be the
hair yeah so right then and there the
like alright going down the line if
we're doing eight episodes every time we
[ __ ] show Medusa like in my mind when
they were doing the show every time you
saw her like when they shot it she would
just be green screen and this [ __ ] would
be like Doctor Strange escaped just
constantly moving but and that's what we
probably would have gotten if they've
done a feature version but it sounds
like with the episodic budget they're
like well let's find a smart fix and I
will give you that story wise that could
be a cool thing but I wouldn't have done
it in the first episode because most
people don't know these characters like
I know them from the books and [ __ ] so
you're right there's no you're not
invested in how [ __ ] important her
hair is because by the middle of the
first episode they cut it off it feels
like the the first bad decision they
made was making an inhuman show because
it's super [ __ ] expensive to do that
right and also they spent two years on
agents of shield setting up what
Inhumans are they ever mentioning the
moon at all it's just they were the
meetings we don't have the rest of
meeting so there are humans and it's
kids with powers and they're being
hunted and persecuted and all that [ __ ]
mine now it's know there's a [ __ ]
regal battle for power on the moon and
it should use that hair than that hair
and there's a dog that teleports people
places when you're lead never talks I
mean I can't [ __ ] about that you know
[ __ ] man built a career on that [ __ ] but
but yeah well here's my question you've
seen how many episodes they put two
together how many is a total 680 do you
think they do a season two I would say
no except they're doing a season two of
iron fist so yeah but that's Netflix and
Netflix already said the like look [ __ ]
whatever you think about the quality
they busted our servers watching an iron
fist so at the end of the day all they
care about are sheer [ __ ] numbers of
views so making another iron fist is
make sense whether you've cared for the
story or not that just makes sense but
so far like everybody is lining up to
kick that look I've I've been through a
situation where the whole world
go [ __ ] yourself and your [ __ ] movie
so this is familiar to me I'm like oh my
god there's no way out of this there's
no like oh but by episode 3 they got
everybody back particularly because what
you're saying happens in episode 1 is
gonna really [ __ ] piss off fans so I
can't imagine they get to go again man
but who knows maybe it's not air that
like the Netflix thing that they get to
do is never tell you actually how many
people watched it right they can tell
you the service crash we don't know it's
true we don't know if 8 people crash the
servers there 8 million people crash but
we'll know how many I'm the biggest
[ __ ] Iron Fist fan in the world click
[Laughter]
yeah I would not recommend if you have
anything else to do if you're mobile if
your hands work and if you can reach the
remote like unless you're like in a
hospital bed the nurse can bring you
your [ __ ] tape I'm just saying that
harsh I'm gonna go I love I look read a
[ __ ] book i am i would not know if i
would go see in the theater well i don't
have a chance now it's gone it's gone
but I definitely will watch yeah yeah
more screens for it but I'll definitely
watch it on TV 8 episodes is a that's a
slim commitment that's like a defenders
commitment if I made it through the
defenders I'll make it through Inhumans
I think but that is the that is the
bottom of the utility belt my friend
that's everything all right so at this
point in the show we like to open it up
to you folks what do you want to talk
about hands in the air we'll pick topics
Bango yes I'll just translate for the
folks at home and the folks that can
hear in the corner a young man it was
your name
Nathan saying you guys strike me as
Stephen King fans particularly the books
yes we are in the sweet spot for the
books cuz when we were growing up that's
when he was prolific as [ __ ] and drop in
what felt like
[Applause]
you're doing it wrong just go like this
so he was dropping a lot of [ __ ] work
back then I was a big fan of like
Christine The Shining Cujo
what else did I read the stand so I you
know I yeah he's a part of the pop
culture DNA why do you ask
well yes I don't know if it's a Stephen
King fevers at a fever pitch yeah but
one nobody remembers nobody wants to
talk about Dark Tower but everyone's
happy to talk about it and stuff but
yeah I would say there Stephen King's
the name is on lips more than it has
been the last few years absolutely
you wrote a book called on writing you
wrote a book called on writing which is
beautiful because half the book is
talking about how he writes like what's
in his toolbox that the the way that he
construct stories and why he to
construct some that way and half the
book is a sort of memoir about why he
writes and why writing ended up being
the lifeline after he got hit by a van
while walking in the streets of Maine
and crushed his spine and shattered his
knees and just the the the ongoing
almost year-long rehabilitation for
finding his passion to live again what's
getting to write again and it's weird
for that guy because there was a there
was a stretch of time especially in the
early in his career when he took writing
for granted he will tell the story and
and I'm not telling stories at a school
but he wrote Cujo in a weekend he was on
a coke bender
and he remembers Friday night sitting
sitting at his [ __ ] typewriter and
then Monday morning seeing a wad of
bloody tissues in the garbage can and a
manuscript on his desk and the
manuscript was crucial he has no memory
of writing that book which he wrote in
the weekend Wow yeah and so like he's
had a tortured relationship with the
word but reading that on writing book is
not only invaluable as a writer but it's
invaluable as to why that dude writes
and what what it means to him to be able
to tell stories about things under the
bed and [ __ ] in the closet and demon
cars and angry clowns I would say the
shining is a great example of his
[ __ ] work and it's it's big thick I
mean a lot of people point to the stand
but the the shining is pretty self
contained on it house story involved but
it's really about a family kind of in
crisis and living with the specter of
like one bad deed but you know it's also
got the book has [ __ ] that the movie
doesn't there's no hedge maze in the
book but there's hedge animals that come
to life which are kind of cool and read
well on the page but I'll be honest with
you I like the hedge maze better than I
like the hedge animals like that Kubrick
movie is pretty wonderful and I know he
didn't care for it himself like he's
always had a problem with it but I it's
it has ever it has the spirit of the
book and a lot of the same material but
the deviations I thought were pretty
strong you yeah I mean I know like
Stephen gates problem with the book I
mean I'm served apartment with a Lube is
that a casting Jack Nicholson tells the
audience he's going to go crazy because
that's what Jack Nicholson does true and
so there's no suspense
that's why Stephen who ever won they did
the miniseries like when it happened
everyone's like who the [ __ ] would
jeopardy dentist Nicholson shoes who the
guy from wings but number one he's way
talented and number two probably a
better choice because you're right you
don't miss initially you don't go off
the battle of this guy's gonna [ __ ]
lose if it doesn't tip it and he had a
problem that that Stanley Kubrick was an
atheist and he didn't believe that
somebody who didn't have a fear of Hell
could understand what
scares people on a metaphysical level um
is that right so what does he consider
himself Christian some way like he does
he believes or at least he was raised
Dennis who's raised that way so he has
the fundamental bedrock of this is this
is how [ __ ] goes wrong on a religious
spiritual level that's common and if you
look at that movie it is a chilly movie
like you got and by design it's a chilly
movie but you can tell that that's dude
who is not coming at it from a place of
belief it's coming from a place of like
I'm just going to scare you with [ __ ]
hmm not I'm gonna work my way into your
soul and scare you with what I find
there Christine is a book that actually
would read well now in this climate too
because it's a bully story it's about a
story about a kid who just gets bullied
to the point of no return and then gets
possessed by a demon car and you know
I'm not even doing a justice it's a way
better [ __ ] read and and the John
Carpenter movie is great I was a big fan
of it and stuff it doesn't come close to
the book but I loved when that movie
came out saw it three times in a movie
theater and stuff but it's it's a pretty
compelling read and it actually works
now as well I would say if you're if
you've never done any king wade into
that one it's pretty easy did you have
any different seasons uh I did that's
the short story one yeah it's got the
body and the bodies and then yeah I mean
it's very tastic there's there is not a
ton of Stephen King that's not good
there is Stephen King that's not good
but it's not good
needful things is a piece of [ __ ] is it
real it really is and I and I know this
because I read it when I got the Castle
Rock job we had a list of stories that
took place in Castle Rock okay
and beautiful thing is one of them
that's holier and Alan Pangborn is the
main character and Alan Pangborn is in
our show like Scott Glenn is playing
Alan Pangborn and Castle Rock and so we
went deep and like read as much stuff as
we could and that's not a good book and
it's a worst book when Stephen King is
reading it to you because he narrates
the audiobook and so Stephen King and
kind of like high reading Maine accent
talking about sex is the most
uncomfortable conversation but no it's
not good they remember the Rick and
Morty episodes the Rick amore episode
where they do needful things I've only
ever seen one episode of Rick and Morty
which one oh my god
he's jumping aah he's Jay he's he's
waiting into it now which one did you
try because my son is watching it my son
is now 13 my wife was not happy that my
son is and I'm fine with it because I
feel like a 13 year old should start
watching [ __ ] that will make their
parents unhappy that the matching [ __ ]
that's a rite of passage but I saw
pickle Rick which is phenomenal
this is for a 13 year old by the way but
this show is it's always insanely
inventive it brings me nothing but joy
I've never seen a week episode all the
ideas are kind of fresh or spins on
tropes from sci-fi and stuff and at its
core is this weird broken family drama
that's just like [ __ ] mind-bending
and like calls to mind not my family I
don't look it and go like there's my
family but I go that's Bryan Johnson's
family like people like this is [ __ ]
up like Bret like Rick reminds me of
Bryan Johnson so much like that is
pretty much who he is in real life and
[ __ ] so I was not surprised to find out
that he was a fan but they've had two
great seasons prior to this season this
season three and I swear to god like
they took a year and change off and
every episode has been epic like classic
instant classic television they're
Vindicator episode was [ __ ] brilliant
they went to they did one episode where
they went to like a like a spa planet to
detox and the detox machine separated
their toxic selves from their
personalities and [ __ ] like just
ingenious crap like that and then the
recent episode the one that was this
week they like did a kind of yeah an
anthology is excellent call anthology
series set on like the Citadel the
Rick's it
which like is featured in a few episodes
including the season premiere this but
it's like you know it opens with our
main characters going on an adventure
and then we don't go on that adventure
we just go to the citadel and it was
[ __ ] mind-bendingly good like they
did what they were doing
Rick and Morty as a plant you know the
Citadel has all Rick's and all Morty's
so there's a big chasm between the
Rick's and the Morty's and there's a
morty town and stuff like that where
rick lists Morty's hang out and get into
trouble and [ __ ] but they had this one
shot where like there's like there's a
Rick who's like joined the force as a
new cop and he gets in the car with an
older Morty and he's just like you know
yeah you're partnered with the morni is
that a problem for you and [ __ ] like
that so while they're driving it's very
much like training day in the background
there's a [ __ ] young Morty like
looking Matt on a bike rolling right up
to him that was like straight out of
[ __ ] trailer then I was dying man it
was [ __ ] pitch perfect so yeah it's
worth it go deep on yeah go do concealer
Stephen King no Stephen King I want to
point out remember like he directed a
movie that's Maximum Overdrive and I
remember before the movie came out we
were all we couldn't wait to see it
because he put the green goblin face on
the front of the truck now nowadays like
they've done Green Goblin the movies
bunch of times and [ __ ] but back then
that was like one of the only comic book
things you'd seen in a movie in a long
time and like you were like oh my god
it's the [ __ ] Green Goblin head and
only some people knew what it was some
people just thought like that's cool
what is that and if you could describe
what it was then you got beat up because
like you [ __ ] nerd
but I you know I give him props for that
that was a dude who like kept Marvel
love alive when there was nobody [ __ ]
love and Marvel out there alright where
do we go next what do you guys got
somebody anybody
what's up we'll go there next over here
first alright the question is with the
recent spate one would say of firings at
Star Wars does this is the message what
that the directors creative vision
doesn't matter and why would another
director even want to come in I think
the second question is easy to answer
[ __ ] you get to play with Star Wars
and stuff so anybody you know I'm sure
if they were like you get to do it but
bend over they do it man because it's
Star Wars and I think jumping in to that
world you especially now you know that
you're not there to do your [ __ ] like
I'm gonna believe me I'm not I'm only I
can use this comparison and I'm not
saying I'm not comparing myself quality
wise but these CW shows that I've been
doing on our microcosm of what those
movies are which is you are there to
serve somebody else's vision in the case
of Supergirl I'm not making my show
you think I'm it make him if I was
making an episode of Supergirl people
would say [ __ ] a lot more so I'm
not making my show I'm making injures
Kreisberg show so you go in with the
agreement that like I'm playing in your
sandbox I'm here to do your thing and
hopefully I'll execute it if not
elevated but I'm not here to do my thing
at all
now you could find little spaces to
express yourself and stuff but that's
not your playground that's not your form
to be self expressive they want somebody
to captain the ship just like you know
and whenever they hire a captain for a
boat they're not like what are your
dreams like you know they just want to
know can you get this boat from [ __ ]
point A to point B and not sink it
they're like good because we got a
schedule and [ __ ] like that so
you want to be like expressive and
[ __ ] artsy or have a vision just know
that you're not in that world you could
bring some [ __ ] to it and be like hey I
think it'd be cool if we did pork so
that looks like that's what Rian Johnson
did he created a little something made
its mark and whatnot but I don't think
you could go into that world going like
now it's me time and that not at all man
they'll [ __ ] put you in
carbon-freezing and get you the [ __ ] out
of there so I don't think it's a bad
thing I don't think it sends a very
clear message and that message should be
you know if I can read loud and clear by
anybody who's even remotely interested
in doing one of those like if you're not
toeing the company line we'll let you go
we don't want you here we're making Star
Wars we're not making your Star Wars
we're making Star Wars so I get it
that's I'm not saying that's why I'm not
doing Star Wars believe me there's a
zillion reasons they would never let me
near it but even if they were like hey
do you want to do one I would have a
real soul-searching moment going like
you know all right well this is like
doing an episode of Supergirl times a
thousand like in those eight days that
I'm up there I'm doing somebody else's
stuff and it's not my time my time will
be when I [ __ ] leave there and I can
go make Jay and Silent Bob reboot so I
think everyone goes in with the
understanding now if you believe the
Articles that they wrote about Colin
Trevorrow or Trevorrow after he got
fired they started throwing him under
the bus and people start going like wow
he's tough to deal with and he had a lot
of opinions and [ __ ] like honestly that
one killed me though like he had a lot
of opinions and like that's the
director's job is to have a lot of
[ __ ] opinions but that's the
director's job on other shows not on
this this is a [ __ ] multi-billion
dollar franchise they don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody's vision but the overall
[ __ ] vision of like caffee or
whatever whoever is in charge of Disney
and stuff like that and it's by
committee it's not even one person over
there it's like they're trying to make
franchises so I get it and anybody
walking into that room should get it too
and now they will because they've
watched four people get [ __ ] thrown
off and two of them didn't even get to a
set two of them were just in theory
gonna direct and they [ __ ] poop poop
and then two
dudes I don't know much in this world
but I know the [ __ ] Lord and Miller
dudes or [ __ ] geniuses because
there's two movies they made three
movies really where when I heard about
all three I'm like you're out of your
[ __ ] Michael [ __ ] yourself I'd never
watch that 21 Jump Street [ __ ] you and I
saw and I was like this is hands-down
the funniest r-rated [ __ ] comedy that
I've seen in the last 10 years this is
where we could go you can have a scene
where a dude picks his own dick up with
his mouth take all my money you know and
then the lego movie when they announce
the lego movie I'm like Jesus suck a
little corporate dick a little more why
don't you have [ __ ] Legos and [ __ ]
and hands down as one of the 10 greatest
films I've seen in my life makes me feel
joyous you know and it's not just a
movie that's like boy that was a fun two
hours it's the kind of art you want to
pass on to other people because it
inspires in the [ __ ] like that so those
cats I know they're nothing but talented
and those cats got [ __ ] fired so that
tells you they're not interested in
anybody's vision over there but theirs
and you know as long as you know that
walking into the cantina you can have a
great time ryan johnson apparently you
hear no complaints out of him you hear
no complaints in the studio about him
there's been no drama whatsoever so and
he's a guy who's got vision you see Luke
where that's a brilliant [ __ ] movie
you go back see brick same [ __ ] thing
so clearly there's a guy with vision but
he walked into that room and he's like
I'm gonna shut this off for now cuz this
is not the time or place and I'll get
back to my [ __ ] but while I'm here I'm
gonna do their [ __ ] but I'm gonna do the
best [ __ ] job I can and where I can
add stuff I can add stuff but I'm here
to do somebody else that you are
literally being hired you know and I'm
lucky because I make my own [ __ ] and so
I'm my own boss but in that world you're
we got a boss when I go to Supergirl or
flash I got a boss and you got a [ __ ]
tow the line and tell somebody else's
story so as long as you accept that
going in you'd be fine and it seems like
in the one case of Colin like you know
they were like well he didn't get along
with Cathy and they didn't see eye to
eye in the case of Josh Trank I mean
they didn't even get there's no script
or anything like that that was based on
I guess Fantastic Four Lord and Miller
dude I don't know how the [ __ ] you get
one week out from rap
and go [ __ ] these dudes like you can add
the the that must there's a story there
and I don't think we're ever gonna see
that movie they made I think we'll see a
tiny percentage of footage it sounds
like now they're getting them further
and further away at first it was like
Ron Howard's doing reshoots but it
sounds like Ron Howard's adding
characters and it's going in a
completely different direction and
that's their prerogative and stuff but I
think anybody walking in that room
understands now that you're not there
for you and if you want to be artsy and
expressive you can kind of go do that
Colin wanted to do that apparently you
know I did Jurassic world it was [ __ ]
massive and then they're like you're
doing Star Wars next he's like well I'll
do some Marty between them and did book
a Henry and a lot of people say that
that's what lost him well he didn't like
it but a lot of people say that was a
factor in him losing the [ __ ] job
like you think anybody over there wants
to hear about vision and [ __ ] no man
they want to know about dates can you
keep it under budget
what kind of cast can you get will you
bring it in on time and [ __ ] people
gonna be happy on set those are the
things that like [ __ ] matter in that
world people like Steven spielberger of
course is different for him he's an
auteur if I could build his own thing
and stuff but those Marvel movies and
Star Wars movies as we've now seen are
they're hitting schedules and they've
got puppet masters like in the case of
Marvel Kevin Feige is the filmmaker
they're like they hire people to direct
the movies but that guy is telling one
massive story and has been doing so for
the last what 12 years 16 movies and
stuff and it's like what they're trying
to do it at Disney now with Star Wars so
like we're gonna try to tell a massive
sprawling story they don't have a
central figure like foggy who's also
kind of like coming up with story
Kathy's very much in charge from
everything we've seen but she doesn't
seem like a story person as much as
Kevin Feige does so I don't know where
I'm going with this but it's just when
you enter that world you know you're
doing that thing talked to Edgar Wright
man like I just read another story where
Edgar Wright you know they talked about
there's I don't know who did it was a
variety or Hollywood Reporter is like
what's the big deal all these [ __ ]
directors getting fired directors used
to mean something in this town and you
know they talked to Edgar Wright who was
on Ant Man for like [ __ ] years he
gave me that script a decade ago he's
like I'm working on at man he won't to
read it I was like
never make that [ __ ] give me that script
and I read it I was like holy [ __ ] this
is amazing I wish they'd make it and
then they didn't make that when they
made another one and [ __ ] like that
so eventually like heat walked away
because in the thing I read like they
asked if they could bring on another
writer he'd been on that project for
what six years working on that script
and then one day Marvel was like we're
gonna bring in someone else to do a
draft and that was the line for him he's
like then it's not me anymore and it
sucked for him to walk away but he did
and anyone made baby driver and
everything [ __ ] worked out he got to
do his thing
so it's it's you know it's it's a
trade-off you get to play with the big
toys you just got to leave your
personality at home and do their thing
and if you're up for that then then
great and then now they've sent a very
clear message anyone coming into this
room has to be kind of up for that but
the kid is different with JJ though
because JJ has his own powerful entity
you know what I'm saying like we saw
that when he made Star Wars he he's his
own universe like he's his own generator
he could do anything he wants so he's
almost the exception in that rule
because I know he had [ __ ] huge
freedom on force awakens and they
brought him back so clearly you know
they respect that guy and he has a
vision but I think he also plays within
the confines they're setting up I know
it's an interesting question though but
for me it's it's plain as day if you're
entering into that world you know check
your ego at the door it's no longer
about you and if you want to express
yourself there's every place else in the
world to do it just not in their
backyard
that sounds like a bummer but I didn't
it's not a lecture it's just an
observation alright we're going over
here so yes go ahead all the photos of
Hellboy I saw the picture did you see it
yeah he looks like hell boy does he look
more like Hellboy than Ron Perlman he
looks like the Hellboy he was also in a
bike again in a way that Ron Perlman
didn't oh really
yeah like there's there some kind of
just windswept about David harvard's
Hellboy who really is
sweaty and [ __ ] bare porn but like
like WWE biker gang there's a little bit
of like Undertaker going on
he's got the sawed-off horns but I guess
you would [ __ ] have to in order to be
that character I know I got a look at
pictures of them side by side I didn't
thought to like compare it to the other
one but he looked like Hellboy to me
when I saw the picture Isaac right on
yeah and then they just cast that dude
dropped out what was his name yeah ed
skrein he dropped up and now they're
casting angled Achim right on so that
worked out for them as well yeah but
yeah I'm all for it like you know I
think it's a good idea I think it's
crazy that the Guillermo didn't get to
do another one but you know but his
movie [ __ ] he don't need it once again
you can play in somebody else's backyard
and he definitely made that his own he
had a lot more freedom with Hellboy but
he didn't do another Hellboy instead he
went to make that new movie he's just
one of the shape of water he want to
[ __ ] the award at Venice it looks
breathtakingly beautiful when I saw the
trailer I tweeted I was like I see [ __ ]
like this makes me ashamed I've ever
called myself a director like it's
beautiful is it a 'king Lee [ __ ]
beautiful and it sounds phenomenal so
good for him that he wasn't like doing
how boy 3 instead he got to make
something completely original yeah he
had this quote that said you know the
more money you get the less freedom you
it's true and so like to your point if
you're playing with a 2 and a million
dollar budget on the Avengers you're not
making your movie you may need somebody
else's movie but if you're gonna do
shape of water for 20 million dollars
that's younger yeah see the baby drive
it for 18 million dollars not sure a
movie it's not anybody else's but yours
if you're gonna make yo Gosar's for 4
million dollars the world will tell you
that's your movie
all right where do we go next
wait in the back that's his lock and key
is what's the guy's name Joe Hill and
that's his son correct
do you read the book of your red line
have you never read lock and key that is
that is a big gaping hole in my I mean I
know of it for sure but kids got a good
reputation I could say that much like a
friend of mine reads him frequently and
stuff and then within the business he's
got a nice reputation it's not like all
that [ __ ] guy some people hear about
getting [ __ ] and you're like yeah that
guy I heard about I was like oh good for
him and that's cool but I'm not that
familiar with it so I guess I should
deep dive is it good and it was it was a
comic his last name is Hill so did he do
that to separate himself from his dad
Wow
[ __ ] that was that was his with
Daniel Radcliffe oh right I was a great
movie alright so I'm gonna check out la
it's called lock and key what is the
what's the premise
hmm he's consistent that whole family's
consistent they should move maybe just
once
[Music]
it's a Hulu series Hulu is swinging man
mocking hey man I'm gonna look for it
all right [ __ ] that was good useful
piece of information what about there go
ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe well maybe what we got to do is
try a live one here that'd be fine now
in order to do it naturally like we
would have the sound down so you
couldn't hear it but the movies we're
talking about we're all pretty familiar
with at this point and stuff so we would
provide all the commentary but yeah but
to be fair marks always gone like hey
they want us to do the other movies we
should do them we just haven't gotten
around to it because for me it's a it's
a double-time affair so the night before
I'll sit there and watch the movie and
write down everything that I think is
funny so that when I sit down with him
I'm Michael mark did you know you know I
seem very quick that way so so yeah
we'll do it we'll do it again and maybe
we'll do it here we'll do the live way
oh go ahead yeah Smallville mused a
sinuhe's was the massive here's my I'm
not gonna I don't want to paint it as
deep regret but uh you know I like what
I do and I've liked my career and stuff
I'm the world's biggest Kevin Smith fan
and stuff but years ago and I still have
it I was sent a fax by go and Millar is
that their names afraid Gotham Gotham I
was more it was that I should say the
guys who were in charge of that show and
they were like look it's night I think
it was 97 or 98 and they said that we
human family read about you and Wizard
all the time why don't you come up to
Canada and direct an episode of
Smallville and this was at a time I
didn't watch Smallville Jason Mewes
watched it and [ __ ] loved it and
would constantly be like you have to
watch it with me and I'm like we're not
12 like you can
you can enjoy it and I don't have to and
for years tried to get me into it and
stuff and then when they asked me to
come directing an episode it was like oh
my god you have to go cuz then I could
be in it too but I never got back
intentions them and not because I was
like a [ __ ] TV poopoo I was just
working on my [ __ ] like I was very
myopic I was chasing amy Dogma and that
corridor and stuff but now like that
I've done five-seat up and episodes of
CW shows and stuff like three super
girls and two flashes like I regret that
I could have started this [ __ ] earlier
like way earlier I could have been doing
this back then like through the who
knows what kind of career I would have
now with a little confidence under my
prodigious belt because like I used to
look at special effects oriented things
and be like I can't do that like that's
why there's not a lot of special effects
in my movies because I'm like that seems
time consuming and long and I don't know
how to do that [ __ ] but now that I've
worked on like these shows like up in
Vancouver like I get it like I couldn't
get my head around it because how I used
to direct before I was like I have to do
everything I write it and I [ __ ]
direct it and I edit it and I [ __ ]
I'll bring your doughnuts during the day
like I do everything and now I realize
that the only way those movies get made
the only way that you can make the even
the Star Wars movies is like it's about
letting go it's about not doing
everything it's about like going like
this is my space and I'm gonna stay in
it I guarantee you if I went up to
direct Smallville back in the day I
would have been an intolerable [ __ ]
because I would have been like no we
have to shoot it like clerks one long
shot black-and-white like that's what I
bring to it and [ __ ] and you realize
that like you know that's the the people
that come back and direct time and time
again on those shows go with the process
they don't go in there and try to
express themselves they don't go like
hey man let me [ __ ] show you [ __ ]
how to make Supergirl they've made it
more times than you'll ever make that
thing so I you know I don't know called
maturity or whatever but like I'm
hitting it at this place now in my
career imagine if I had done it back in
like 98 because now I could be on a set
and be like oh I can have a
for a big special effect thing because I
know I'm not responsible for it like on
Supergirl flash like the whole third
active of the not act third act act five
of our episode there's six acts in the
show act five is the big special effects
sequence I don't wanna spoil it but you
know shooting that sequence was limited
because most of the heavy lifting is
going to be done by this guy Armen who
builds all the special effects in flash
and Supergirl he's the guy who built
Grodd and king shark like makes him
believable and stuff like that so this
whole act like as we cut the episode I
was watching mostly storyboards for act
5 because Arman's still building that
sequence and you know now I'm old enough
to be like that's great like Armen does
his thing I don't have to be up in it
he'll carry his piece this personal
carry this piece blah blah blah whereas
back in the day I would have been like
no I have to do this special effects and
I have to learn how to do that if I
don't know how to do that there's no
point in doing it because a director
does everything and now I'm old enough
to know that like there are many kinds
of directors like on my [ __ ] I can be
the guy that's up in the grill of
everything but when it comes to those
things that doesn't help
in fact it hurts the [ __ ] process and
in doing so and becoming a little more
grown-up about it and then going like
this is not me forever this is just the
director I am when I'm here this is the
director they need they don't want the
other guy you know who's just like I'm
gonna have him [ __ ] say [ __ ] smoker
like you just they want somebody who's
staying on point with the script and
shooting the show and making it look
like it so if I had done Smallville back
in the day I would have seen Oh special
effects aren't anything to be scared of
like we can pull this [ __ ] off like a
lot of people that work on our shows now
are the shows that I've worked on came
from Smallville like it's crazy a lot
I'll be sitting on Sep talking to people
and they're like well when we were I
remember we did the Legion of
super-heroes on Smallville and I was
like you weren't [ __ ] Smallville like
oh yeah and so like there's nothing new
like I'm like I can't believe they're
doing Legion like I can cuz we did it on
Smallville 10 years ago so I there's a
part of me like whenever I look at that
letter and I've saved it is I'm
regretful I'm I wish that I had I wish I
had been a different person at that
point like adventurous now I'm a STONER
so people like hey you want to try
something I'm like
yeah let's direct the Goldbergs you know
so back then though people like hey you
want to try something like no no no I
got my thing going on I'm good thank you
very much and stuff like that but now
it's like now I'm a little more
adventurous now I'm less insecure in
terms of like well I don't want anyone
to see how I do this job they'll realize
I don't know what I'm doing you know
there's a fear that you're a fraud at
all times because there's no job
description you know for director it
changes from place to place and you can
make it what you want as well so back
then I didn't have enough I didn't have
enough confidence I think to go up and
direct an episode ironically enough go
up to direct an episode of Smallville
because I was afraid I'd be found out to
be a sham though I liked clerks but this
guy is a [ __ ] idiot you know now I'm
[ __ ] smart enough to like get on the
set and be like I don't know anything
you know I just put it on Front Street
and guess what happens someone will tell
you what you need to know so there's no
more fear of like a hot [ __ ] they'll
find out I'm a fraud I start day one
going I'm a fraud I need you all teach
me how you make what is essentially half
of a [ __ ] feature film in eight days
and I'm talking about a big-budget
feature film because like in the case of
flash it's a show where spoilers the boy
solves all his problems by running
[ __ ] fast
so every week they had show ends like
that who like [ __ ] Barry there's only
one way to stop him he's like I get it
I'll run you know any [ __ ] Ron's
again at you and so that you know that
that would have been nice training they
did that on Smallville I'm sure the same
kind of structure and stuff where you
tell little stories and then there's a
big action sequence so I don't you know
I wish that I had been confident enough
to do that back in the day but life is
not about regret it's like hey there's
still time while you're above ground you
make it right and so me doing these CW
shows I'm gone oh great alright well I
do get a chance to do it and there's a
mild regret for not having done it ten
years ago because who knows where I'd be
right now maybe I'd be more confident
enough to like try to tackle a [ __ ]
superhero movie or something but you
know it's a small tiny regret and stuff
but yeah but that's that was my
Smallville story good
I wasn't looking I wasn't like please
applaud now I just want to make sure we
covered all the bases yes did I go to
USC I that means a lot thank you I now
have a vague recollection of that USC
screening because I never went to USC
very often but I did go with Scott when
you said Scott I was like I remember
that
[Applause]
do you know number one that's that's
sweet and thank you for remembering but
you know what happened that weekend so
like I was here in town and I was doing
press for the movie and then we had the
screening at USC and I went on K rock
for I think the first time in my life
and you know I do podcast with Ralph
Garman called Hollywood babble-on and
he's been on that show forever but when
I went there in 94 he I don't think he
was working on the show yet so I was on
the radio in the area and talking about
the movie and stuff like that and I'm
from New Jersey blah blah blah and then
I was driving back from k-rock to the
hotel and it was I had an earliest
version of a cell phone that we rented
it at the airport Scott's like we're
here on business we should get a mobile
phone so we had this [ __ ] ten-foot
phone and [ __ ] like that and my I got a
phone call on that phone while I was
passing that building [ __ ] maybe it's
the Mormon Tabernacle building or
something like that or what is it yes is
that the Mormon Tabernacle book so I was
passing that building it's got a big
lawn and [ __ ] like that yes so I was
passing that building and I answered the
phone and it was a friend of mine from
high school a female friend of mine who
like we were always close but like Oh
Kevin I could never [ __ ] you you're like
a brother and I'm like well I
I would love to [ __ ] my sister but you
know she would
so we were friends throughout high
school and whatnot
and she called me because she was like
oh my god like she'd moved out to Los
Angeles I'm going to go to school and
she was like I was [ __ ] listening to
the radio and all the sudden I heard you
talking and I like I was trying to reach
the radio station so I called your house
and your dad gave me this number and I
was like hey man how are you and she's
like what are you doing on the radio I
was like I made this movie and [ __ ] and
she's like oh we got to get together and
we did we booked she's still like we're
so good friends so they said we don't do
that anymore but like we're still very
good friends but anyway when you say
this moment you were like Scott USC I
was like that's when I had sex that long
ago but anyway I'm sure you got a real
question yes though with him as the
Clive Barker guy or like when do we get
to talk to CB of we world right I look
up at this point at this point I will
try like directing anything because
generally there tend to be not long jobs
like at the most like Supergirl flash is
about three weeks one week of prep and
then eight nine days of shooting so it's
like a three-week experience so unless
they were like hey this is a show where
we [ __ ] stomp on puppies I go and try
it out and [ __ ] so if that came into
fruition I would give it a shot have I
heard anything about
absolutely not do I hang out at CW not
if not at all when I when I'm when I'm
involved with the show and like it there
I'm usually on set and that's far from
CW up in Vancouver and then today I was
at the production offices of Berlanti
and stuff so I've rarely ever interact
with with the network or anything so
I've haven't heard I haven't heard hide
nor hair but it's it's so funny it's
live that you brought up like a lot of
Stephen King talk and stuff like I
remember back in the day Stephen King
Clive Barker were like the Michael
Jackson or Prince argument like who do
you like and you're like I'd like them
both you can't like both you know but I
loved Nightbreed and I loved the fact
that he cast what's-his-name the
director as the Oh [ __ ] Cronenberg's
performance in that movies were the most
chilling things I've ever seen in movie
he has this [ __ ] calm voice where
it's just like now I'm gonna stab you
like it's just really [ __ ] chilling
and his mask was fantastic it was the
inspiration for the onomatopoeia
character that I did for Green Arrow and
[ __ ] just that face mask and we put
concentric circles but he had like the
little [ __ ] button here and the
zipper here ah so [ __ ] good I mean
the numbers in in television are such
that almost no shows that ever get
bought get made you know is that true
like every development season every
executive will hear somewhere between
500 and 700 pitches for shows they will
buy 200 pitches they will commission 100
scripts they will order 40 pilots they
will put 15 shows in the air
the odds of ever seen we've world at
this point in that incarnation are slim
to none not to say that at some point
clap can't sell it again to sci-fi or
sell it again two stars so it again to
wherever but that particular version of
it like if we haven't seen it we're
probably not good it was as I heard
mentioned earlier I went out on pitches
this week four pitches and I'm doing
that much in my career I never really
had to I pitched Mallrats at the black
tower and Universal lot once and that
worked out they bought the movie and we
got to make the movie I never really had
to pitch any of the movies
Miramax Harvey was just like what are
you doing what do you want to do and I
was I going to do this I would just hand
him a script and he'd read and be like
alright great so I didn't really never
had to pitch that much and the few
pitching experiences were always
uncomfortable because there is real hat
and hand experience you've got to engage
people with your idea and as an indie
filmmaker that's not in my DNA my DNA
says like I don't care if anyone likes
it I'm gonna do it myself and stuff but
when you're involved in stuff that
involves a studio or network there's a
lot of pitching so I went out recently
this week with a pitch for a really
great series that I hope goes and it's
not it's not me it's not mine I didn't
create it it's a docu-series there are
these boys that made this documentary
last year that I [ __ ] loved I talked
about I think on Hollywood babble-on it
was called I am Big Bird is the story of
Caroll Spinney the guy who played Big
Bird for years the documentary is like
wonderful human story about somebody who
is in our lives from the moment were
born like you can't avoid Big Bird in
this world and at one point like Big
Bird was your friend and [ __ ] like that
and you know for years I am a nerd so I
knew that Big Bird's name was Carol
Spenny but the whole world doesn't know
that so the doc was a real great insight
into the man that formed the character
of Big Bird not just like I put on the
suit but like Big Bird is the way he is
he speaks the way he speaks he is gentle
and kind because of the guy in the suit
it's not like Caroll Spinney takes off
the suit and he's just like I want to
get blown you know maybe he does but
he's a real [ __ ] nice guy and that
informs his character in his childhood
informed who Big Bird who became as well
so the boys came up with an idea to keep
it going like my agency William Morris
was like hey man do you know or William
Morris Endeavor they were like do you
know I am Big Bird I was like [ __ ] of
course I do I was like I would eyeballed
about it last year and I talked about on
Hollywood babble-on and he was like yeah
the filmmakers knew that you were a big
fan so they asked if you wanted to be
involved in this show that we're gonna
go out and pitch and I was like what is
it I was look I'd love to be involved so
I like their work
and he goes they want to do it as a
series and so
like look I'm all for it but how many
[ __ ] times can you tell the Caroll
Spinney story like what what is this
like a reality show or something so no
no it's not about Caroll Spinney they
want to do that for a lot of people so
the idea of the show it's called life in
costume and it's about the people that
play the parts that you know so well but
rarely ever see their face so it would
be like Anthony Daniels or Peter Mayhew
or Tara Strong who's done the voice of
[ __ ] every animated character in the
last 10 years 15 years or Nancy
Cartwright who played part you know
somebody who's part of your daily DNA or
pop-culture DNA but maybe you don't
you've never seen them before so we
pitched so far four different places
they pitched two places today without me
and I think we have two other places to
do and you know at one point we were
coming out of AMC and you know I've had
good luck at AMC I've had a few shows
there but anything I've ever done at AMC
has not been me walking into AMC going
let me pitch you this thing everything
was them coming to me comic book men
they came to me through a weird backdoor
geeking out they came to me they were
like we bought this show would you like
to co-host it and stuff you know I'm in
the comic book documentary that Robert
put together Kirkman and stuff so
anytime I've ever been on the channel
AMC has come to me and I've gone to AMC
many times to pitch things to be like
this is something I want to do and each
time you know AMC's been like oh no not
this one and stuff so generally speaking
you know I know my place which is when
they call me I'm happy to [ __ ] show
up but like unless I want to go in and
keep getting my heart broken by being
like do you guys want to do this and
they're like no there's no point in kind
of continuing then so we're coming out
of the AMC thing we pitched it and I
thought it would be a really good fit at
AMC because they're doing docu-series
now and I was like this feels like it I
don't know that it's gonna wind up there
and if I had to guess based on the vibe
in the room probably not so we were
downstairs it was me and the two
filmmakers and the guy that runs hit and
run which is the studio
the production company they'll be making
it so we were downstairs in the where's
over in Santa Monica they got those four
buildings like we're Amazon isn't she
like I forget
called so we're in the parking lot and
you know we're having the discussion
after you pitch you're like how do you
think it went blah blah blah and so I
was like my take I don't know I don't
think it's gonna I don't think we'll
find a home there it's like which is
weird cuz it would fit very nicely
between their comic book and their
sci-fi miniseries documenting series but
I said but you know at the end of the
day I was like I can't be mad like that
they're not going for it you know and
they're like yeah but you've got shows
there I was like oh yeah but this
process is so [ __ ] up because it's
like we walk into a room and we're like
hey man like we think it'd be fun do
this can we have a couple million
dollars so of course like there's this
system of if you're lucky enough to get
into the room to pitch and if you're
lucky enough that they picked the pitch
up if you're lucky enough that they
[ __ ] pay you to write it or develop
it and if you're lucky enough that they
decide to go to [ __ ] pilot and if
you're lucky enough that they decide to
go to series like it is so many steps
and all the steps are designed to not
make something like to make a difficult
and [ __ ] like that
that's the gamut that everyone runs
through it's a miracle than anything
happens it didn't gets on to gets on TV
or it gets made at a studio that's why
we're in this golden age where now you
have all these people creating channels
and exhibition platforms which means
they need content they need content more
than ever
so now way more shits getting made than
has ever been made before you have way
more opportunities to go into some new
place and you know impress them with a
good idea my problem is I've got a long
tail and so I've done some [ __ ] that
people like and so when you know they're
like hey Kevin Smith wants to come in
with a pitch people like oh my god
that's great yeah totally bring him in
and I realize some people just want to
like say hi some people just want to
meet you and that's it they're not
interested in the idea at all and you
know as you start telling them like the
pre conversation is amazing they'll sit
there and go deep on your on your career
and whatnot like [ __ ] I love you I love
everything about you man I love your
[ __ ] style love the way you have you
hand you a professional career I want to
be in business with you like great okay
so we got this show called life in
costume you just watch their faces draw
we're the like it's about Big Bird no
well good see you Simon pop you know and
then off you [ __ ] go so it's amazing
that anything [ __ ] winds up happening
and some things get bought or picked up
and you're like [ __ ] if they picked it
up it's definitely gonna move to Ceres
but then they just don't want up happen
Greg Berlanti is that insane [ __ ] I
don't know what you call it luck talent
ability in pitching shows that go on
that get on and I used to sit there
sometimes back in the day and be like
[ __ ] man everyone loves Jay Jay like Jay
Jay can do no wrong Jay Jay goes into
pitches and they pick up Jay Jay show
always I was like [ __ ] I wish I was as
talented as [ __ ] Jay Jay and then
when I started pitching like I realized
what it is Jay Jay is very talented
don't get me wrong and Jay Jay allies
himself with with [ __ ] great material
and stuff like that but Jay Jay hustles
like you hear about the shows that they
pick up of course that's news but what
you don't hear about are the shows that
he pitches that don't get picked up and
that does happen like the reason he
could get so much on is cuz he will go
in and [ __ ] pitch constantly like
he's smart like that he's like I'm
always going in once a week I guarantee
you he's somewhere pitching something
[ __ ] massive and you hear about the
things that get picked up but you don't
have hear about the things that don't
get picked up and that's the way it goes
but if you did like if you heard like
yeah and I did you doesn't work out
every time for Jay Jay like that gave me
a little more confidence where I was
like oh she had I just assumed he was
born under a lucky star but he just goes
in every time he's a guy that's willing
to hustle willing to go in and trade his
ideas for a job so I that's last year I
realized I was like that's if you want
to be like Jay Jay if you want to like
[ __ ] see a lot of things of yours
just start pitching like crazy and last
year I pitched four things and three got
picked up the one that didn't was
[ __ ] Mallrats so it's a weird process
because you go and hat in hand and stuff
like that and you're literally begging
somebody for [ __ ] money and begging
for a job kind of but when it works it's
[ __ ] glorious like you know you feel
fantastic you like they picked me how
neat and [ __ ] never happens to me but
like I imagine it would feel real good
what's it like for you I mean it's
different
because when I know on these meetings
and I've done quite a bit of them
especially the last couple of weeks it's
uh they don't know me the way they know
you when I walk into a room so it's I
will tell my 45-minute life story that I
will customize to whom Romero talking
about to debate depending on the job
that I'm looking for but and it's it's a
little hat in hand and like I want you
to like me I want you to like me enough
to pay me an exorbitant amount of money
to sit in a room and make up a [ __ ]
story with strangers
yeah and when you get to do what it's
great but a lot of times you're gonna
lie on those meetings and most of them
don't pan out because the easiest word
and Hollywood for them to say is no no
never get you fired
yeah no no never loses you your job no
is they like oh well why didn't you do
that thing I didn't like it anything
would work and you've got to justify a
yes every step up the ladder you got to
go to your boss and say why did you say
yes well I mean it's [ __ ] Jay Jay I
think it's gonna work great - his boss
well why'd you say yes well it's jj+
Stephen King I think it's gonna work
then you go up another and another and
another and every time that person says
yes up until it airs and is anyway hit
or not you've got to justify why you
said yes let's spend a hundred million
dollars on this it's why it's easier
from to say no yeah I mean there's that
old joke about studio executives if they
get away with never green-lighting movie
they would cuz they'd never lose a
[ __ ] job that way but you do lose a
job if you're like hey man you know what
I think would be great Dark Tower you
know and then then it don't work out
know like you said Dark Tower would work
you're like I thought it would and then
you're out on your [ __ ] ass but then
you wind up in another studio and the
whole thing starts again and [ __ ] so
it's it's you know but it's a weird
business
I don't can't think of many other
businesses like it where you know a good
part of your job is to go places and beg
people for ridiculous amounts of money
to tell made-up stories but you know
that's the magic of Hollywood a gamble
hundreds of millions of dollars that
that story will resonate with an
audience who want to pay for the older
you get the more understanding you get
to the process you know when I was a kid
I was like well they [ __ ] do it oh my
god they got all that money you know but
though it's crazy that they ever do it
like you know the older you get you're
like dude can't your blessings they ever
[ __ ] did it
well deeper I get into my career the
more I'm like I can't believe I made
this [ __ ] far on so little gas you
know what I'm saying like it's not like
I'm like here inception you know oh like
two decades ago I was like here clerks
and I'm still living off that [ __ ] so I
can't [ __ ] about thank you see so I
can't [ __ ] about the the process but it
is a weird process when you go in there
you're like please and sometimes it
happens some most times it doesn't my
kids auditioning a lot lately like
sometimes she gets real down and [ __ ]
and I'm like kiddo
you picked a business that is 99.999999
9 no and then that point zero zero zero
one yes is everything it's glorious and
it's the chance at immortality and it's
the chance to do something that makes an
impact and like changes people's lives
and makes people remember you and [ __ ]
like that that's the dream you know
that's why you do it that's you know I
guess some people get to a point where
they're like I've been kicked in the
balls so often [ __ ] it and there have
been time I'd happen to me when I was
pitching Mallrats and I hit six places
and they were like spent an hour with
each one listening to him blow the movie
but like afterwards like yeah I don't
see it as a show and blah blah blah so
you know I told the kid I'm like it just
rejections part of it and if you want a
side step rejection just do your own
[ __ ] like that's that's what i did i
just made [ __ ] and it worked out and
stuff i was like you're the daughter of
two writers and you want to act you can
write your own [ __ ] and then you don't
have to wait for any [ __ ] handouts or
anything like that but still wonderful
business right [ __ ] what else I'm not
qualified to do anything else but beg
people for money yes really that means
the world man is girl don't let her hear
all the kursi parts of course I am that
was the dream for that movie was like oh
little girls it was a movie for little
girls it was my version of strange brew
and when I found strange brew I was like
11 or 12 or something like that
I felt like I found on cable I felt like
the movie was made for me so I was like
I want to make a movie like
who was my version of strange brew with
girls and their superheroes and [ __ ]
like that
and you know one day kids are gonna come
across I didn't expect people were gonna
go see at movie theatres we made a
midnight movie for an audience that
couldn't stay up to see it it's kind of
silly but I figured by the time I got to
Netflix the proper audience would find
and just like Mallrats it would
eventually gravitate to the people that
dug it so whenever I hear like oh my
six-year-old or my kid like small rats
it's uh yo goes it's the [ __ ] same
story over again it makes me happy
because that was the aim like you know
and what I'm counting on is one of these
girls who saw the movie and fell in love
with it stays in love with it their
whole life like like I stay in love with
the movies of my youth and [ __ ] and then
one like I'm an old man and I can't get
hired they're like oh we'll put you in
the movie say snooch to the new ch I'm
like that's the other guy but whatever
let's see go ahead over here yes
that's I love the fact I love the fact
that people like I've heard a few
stories of siblings bonding over the
movies Melissa Melissa on Supergirl
last bless you last episode we were day
one or two of shooting and she was like
my nephew's on the FaceTime can you say
like happy birthday and I was like yeah
it totally has a happy birthday and I'm
like that kid doesn't know to [ __ ] I am
and she goes no he watches comic book
men and I was like oh really
and she's like but my sister was beside
herself and I was like why she goes that
does she love Jay and Silent Bob strike
back and she would bring me into the
room to watch it one summer we watched
that movie over and over and over again
so I like when I hear stuff like that
I'm like oh right on anyway back to you
you inspired her to go back to school
[Applause]
it's the dream figure out what you love
to do and then figure out how to get
paid for it that's that's how you be
happy I mean you may not be [ __ ] rich
but you'll be happiest [ __ ] Brian
Johnson is Rick yeah I told him that the
other day he was just like really I was
like yeah you are the smartest man in
the world
thank you you're rock man thank you my
god it's too much positivity
this thing's gonna bring us down yeah I
think I don't know it seemed for a
minute a lot of people were crowd
funding and then it kind of got a little
quiet we I wanted to do it before a
Kickstarter was invented but we were
gonna we had this website called red
state green where you know on an early
episode of pop SModcast I think maybe
the first or second episode I had you
know as a myspace guy back then so I had
like over a million followers and so I
was like boy mo juror now we're talking
about if I can get every one of them to
give me one buck we can make a [ __ ]
movie and [ __ ] a couple years later they
embedded a website that did that but
before that one existed we were building
one man John Gurdon called red state
green which was to raise money for red
state I was like oh my god I'll go month
to my audience they've always wanted to
say it and [ __ ] like we'll do it that
way
so I was doing an interview in Toronto
for a fee which movie was about to open
maybe it was cop-out and I mentioned
that like oh we built this website we're
gonna you know I don't think they call
that crowdsource financing then we're
gonna I said we're gonna raise the money
to make red state off the audience
because it's the audience that wants to
see it and then someone wrote an article
online where they were like yo Kevin
Smith is gonna beg for money for his
next movie and that scared me and I
[ __ ] I told John Gordon I was like we
can't do this just pull down the website
we'd spent about $25,000 building the
website too and I was like I can't do it
dude I can't do it and you know we would
have been the first like it wound up
being what's his name knew Zach Braff
that's right you know and and it's not
without its it's
- he had to take a little [ __ ] as well
because there were a bunch of people
like I saw what my future might have
been there were bunch of people go on
hey man don't you have money I've seen
your house like warrants why you asking
strangers for money and [ __ ] so I was I
was glad I didn't do that I've kind of
reached this place where I was like that
is for a generation of filmmakers that I
don't belong to like if I'd never made
clerks and [ __ ] and that was open to me
then I would do that even now because I
got the audience for it but now it feels
like like cheating like you know what
I'm saying like I could I could get a
bunch of money because I've got the past
and the longtail and the affection
toward that work but it feels like if I
jumped into that pool I'd be soaking up
a lot of the [ __ ] water that should
be going to people who've never done
this [ __ ] before and I could always like
I can find money okay I got my own money
or I could [ __ ] go and sit in
meetings and stuff like that to soak up
crowdsource financing crowd source
funding financing for myself seems kind
of piggish but I love it I love the idea
of it I think it works for a lot of
people why don't more people do it I
think because of that like you're you
talking about why more established
filmmakers don't do it like the Super
Trouper guys did or just people in
general but they're well-known they've
done [ __ ] exactly but I mean and I would
put myself like right in their sphere of
influence like we're on the same level
on [ __ ] so naturally like there's a part
of me that's like [ __ ] I could do the
same thing I could fund it off off my
audience but I don't want to do that I
rely on the audience for so much like to
buy tickets to this [ __ ] feels weird to
be like hey can you guys pay for it hey
can you pay for tickets to see it - you
know it's like I'm gonna hit him up
later on when I really need him for
tickets I'll if I can't find the money
myself it doesn't seem fair to turn to
the audience to ask where that's for me
but I think for everyone else oh my god
absolutely like if you can get strangers
to give you money that's a big part of
the [ __ ] job like I do you know the
people that I've financed my flicks over
the years like they were strangers I
didn't know the Weinsteins until they
started giving me money for the movies
and stuff so there's always gonna be a
degree of hat-in-hand unless you want to
do it yourself like I did it on
cards the first one and stuff I don't
know even if crowdsource financing
existed back then that I would have had
the confidence to try that because I'd
be like who would want to back this sort
of thing like that's why I went to
credit cards like I'd read
what's-his-name
Sam Raimi did the Evil Dead and there
was a film book I was reading about the
making of Evil Dead and maybe might have
been feature future filmmaking a used
car prices Rick Schmidt's book might be
that I'm not sure but in any event you
know they talked about Sam Raimi when he
had the idea for the Evil Dead he was in
Michigan and stuff he would go around to
dentists area dentists and be like I
want to make a horror movie horrors of
proven genre we're looking for a $5,000
investment for that you'll get this and
blah blah blah and I remember reading
that and being like I don't I don't have
that confidence in my material I
couldn't imagine walking into a
dentist's office with a copy of clerks
you know and being like hey do you want
to hit your wagon to my star
it's like 180 pages full of dick jokes
set in a convenience store I'm sure
it'll do well so instead I went like to
the I had credit cards that I never used
and stuff so I was like let me put it on
credit cards I'd seen other people had
done that
Robert Townsend did it with the
Hollywood shuffle finance part of the
movie on credit cards so I didn't have
enough confidence of me or my ability or
my [ __ ] work or my ideas to go out
into the world and try to raise money so
I don't think I would have tried
crowdsource financing for that reason
but it's it's anybody who's interested
in making a film and looking for loot
they don't have enough loot to do it why
not try it you know at the end of the
day it's like I wouldn't Kickstarter
makes you hit a level or else you don't
get anything but I'm pretty sure
IndieGoGo lets you keep whatever you
raise and if that gets you closer like
go for it like yeah I'm surprised more
people don't do it myself but but to be
fair not everyone wants to make a movie
you know what I'm saying and a lot of
people that do are on Kickstarter and
IndieGoGo my friend Malcolm raised his
whole budget for his recent documentary
from IndieGoGo I think and it was uh
he's doing a it's called southern prides
a documentary about a gay bar and missus
in Tennessee or Mississippi Alabama
that's where it was no [ __ ] I forget
where it was down south in a place where
in a place where having a gay bar isn't
like the [ __ ] first idea most people
haven't stuff so it's you know kind of
about how community builds itself within
a larger community and he did a
documentary years ago called small town
gay bar this is kind of a sequel to it
it was right after Trump got elected and
he was like I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
raise money for this doc it's important
I was like how come where it's right
before Christmas like nobody wants to
[ __ ] put money into your documentary
before Christmas like you should wait
until the beginning of the year and
that's me his friend seasoned veteran
and somebody who's you know got a
[ __ ] some area of expertise in the
subject matter to some degree and
Malcolm was just like I think you're
wrong and he started it and got all this
[ __ ] money like before the holidays I
was like holy [ __ ] dude he's like yeah
people are out there they're mad and
they want this story to be told so
[ __ ] I was able to start right now
and boom he went off and shot us doc so
if anybody out there is listen they're
like I always wanted to try [ __ ] on the
money
give it a shot you just have to be able
to be convincing you we all know how it
works now you've seen the videos that
the people put up on Kickstarter
IndieGoGo or any of those types of sites
it's all about the personal story it's
less about the story you're telling with
your film and more about who you are and
why you're trying to do this that's what
people respond to any time I've ever
dumped money into things and I do it
randomly on Kickstarter and IndieGoGo
it's never been about the project it's
never been about oh [ __ ] I believe in
this about [ __ ] chainsaw hookers you
know it's the video it's the kids making
the video going like you don't
understand chainsaw hookers is
everything you know and I'm like they're
right it is PayPal so yeah if you're
into it you should definitely be trying
it before it goes away right alright one
more and then we got to get out of
here's but ours how are you
finish this out take us someplace
interesting spoilers let me see we did
one season in Hulu we did one season on
comedy in Canada when it was weird as
aggregated from a streaming show to a
television show and then we never did
another season and it wasn't because
they weren't interested we were doing
something else and then periodically we
talked about going back and trying to do
it again I think if we did it again
I would try to do it with IMDB I do a
lot of stuff with IMDB now that seems
like the perfect place for it so maybe a
year from now we'll try to resurrect
that sometimes we build [ __ ] and then
just let it be and walk away like in the
case of spoilers I think we were kind of
knee-deep in comic book men and that's
why spoilers kind of went to the
backburner but I love that show mark was
on an episode you run episode 2 it's fun
all right that was good but let's go out
or more of a question there we go
bang totally yeah we should we can we
should actually pull people in which one
BBS commentary you're gonna make me
watch it again dude I've seen that movie
I just have my wife like I told this
joke many times it's not joke it
actually happened like I was sitting
there watching Batman V Superman on my
laptop for like the 8th time like when
it came out it was like within the day
that it dropped digitally I watched it
eight times within three days and my
wife was like why do you keep watching
this I was like cuz sooner or later I'm
gonna [ __ ] love it I know and I know
it so recently I was we had a
revisitation because I was watching the
Justice League trailer and we had just
seen it in front of it and then when I
got home I watched it again and she was
like why do you keep watching I was like
because it's gonna hit me in a way that
it hasn't hit me yet I know I'm just I'm
waiting for the moment it envelops me oh
yeah we should definitely do Batman V
Superman
I mean I I guess we should do like a
whole review but like there I how to put
this I generally like to just talk about
[ __ ] that I [ __ ] adore and love like
I don't really like to be the guy that's
like man it didn't really work for me
and [ __ ] that's that guy should really
stop doing that because I'm looking for
jobs in television oh you hate
everything we do right yeah I just I
don't I why do I feel that way I well
cuz I do it I make this [ __ ] I know it's
[ __ ] hard and you know nobody sets
out to make a piece of [ __ ] nobody and
sometimes it just [ __ ] happens to you
whether you know whether you're trying
to make something brilliant or not
sometimes you just kind of get screwed
so I feel like it's not my place to be
like [ __ ] these people they [ __ ] it up
even in a nice but I liked it well
here's that I was just saying all that
I'll here's my feelings on the defenders
I'll start this way
I love daredevil season one and then I
think daredevil season two and this
isn't ranking the Netflix series for me
daredevil season one and two at the top
then Luke Cage was fantastic and a total
surprise didn't realize how much I would
enjoy it then Jessica Jones then way
down here is iron fist and somewhere
between iron fist and Jessica Jones is
where the defenders lives for me I yeah
I enjoyed it but I wasn't like daredevil
I binge so hardcore so fast and when I
finished the season went back and
started again and not just because I
like the character I thought I was
insanely gripping storytelling and then
they were able to do it again with
season 2 by adding a lecture and
bringing in the Punisher and stuff so
with this you felt like oh my god it's
got all the characters together and then
[ __ ] squirty Weaver's and it's gonna
be fantastic and it was totally
watchable totally well done nobody's bad
and it's not like they're any weak links
that says I but it didn't like it was it
was well done but I wasn't like oh my
god I gotta tell people about this it's
one or two moments that I was like
that's dope
but you know their final act and this is
not comparisons apples and oranges but
their final act
spoilers five four three two one is
predicated on a dragon skeleton being
hidden under New York City and that's
pretty [ __ ] cool pretty metal and
then two days later Game of Thrones is
like oh we'll show you a dragon you know
and Hogan suddenly we had ice dragons
and [ __ ] then it's wrong to compare that
is not why I was not a huge I liked I
liked the defenders just fine but I
didn't love it as much as I liked
daredevil the two Daredevils so based on
that there was really no like deep dive
- do you know what I'm saying it would
be me kind of doing this and then I'd be
like mark what did you think and he'd
fist [ __ ] it
so what did you think what was your what
was your take on defenders yeah it
wasn't you liked it more than in humans
right um I did like it more than
Inhumans my problem with it is that I
always feel that when you're when you're
doing a culmination of something in the
same way the defenders feels tomorrow TV
what the Avengers felt tomorrow yes and
that we're going to build to a thing yes
and that thing you build to should be
amazing yes should show me things you've
never seen before the the fact that
you've got all these heroes on the stage
at once doing [ __ ] should be a thing I
didn't know I wanted as badly as I as I
did very true the defenders didn't do
that for me the defenders felt like
another episode yeah and I and I'm a
little hard pressed to figure out why
like maybe some of it is resources maybe
they didn't have the money to spend for
a giant [ __ ] story it didn't like
that never it never felt like other
cheaper now like that that wasn't the
thing right I mean those shows are not
about spectacle but never about
spectacle so I'm not expecting that but
I'm expecting import I'm expecting some
sense that what I'm gonna see is seismic
to the universe and and will alter
everything I'd seen before and set the
course for everything that's going to
come after and the finish did he do that
for me
like he just kind of felt like another 8
episodes of the show I like that it was
8 not 13 please III too was a big fan of
those yeah on their TV shows but I just
I wanted so much more from it than I got
and I'm not saying I hated what I got I
really liked 75% of it I agree
but but I just think it needed to land
harder than it did they needed to mean
more than it did and until you can do
that when you have all your [ __ ]
heroes together then I then I just I
find it hard to become motivated for
what's next it wasn't like I I didn't
feel like that this isn't a case of me
going oh I wish they had done this
instead
but in my head so I wasn't setting
myself up from disappointment but in my
head they all came together because
Claire temple got killed and that would
have given it some dramatic weight for
me where I'm like what the [ __ ] they
killed Rosario again that would have
made sense but there was no real great
reason that they all kind of came
together they just kind of came together
yeah and nothing wrong with that but and
again that's not me going they didn't do
what I wanted that just would have been
something that would have made it cool
for me but I liked what they did it just
didn't it wasn't daredevil for me or
even Luke Cage which I Luke Cage and
really snuck up on me I was like this is
[ __ ] incredible
I was not expecting that to be as as
gripping as it was and they did daring
things with the storytelling like spoil
I mean everyone's seen it now but
spoilers five four three two one they
get rid of their bad guy like halfway
through the show and they're like here's
the real bad guy that's kind of bold and
the bad guy they got rid of is a genius
actor so it's and then they also did
something in that which I've [ __ ]
dearly loved the fight at the end looks
like a comic book like [ __ ] the bad
guy looks like a comic book character
but there's a good reason for it he's
got an armor on so that it could fight
this guy that's indestructible and
suddenly they get closer and closer to
the source material so I love that one
and Jessica Jones same thing I thought
that was daring never
imagine there'd be Marvel anything where
a plot point was an aborted fetus that
was so [ __ ] up I remember like
rewinding going this is a Marvel thing
did they just say abortion did they just
say that this aborted fetus is a part of
the plot holy [ __ ]
and nobody made us think about it no
Christian groups came out of the work
woodwork to say anything or anything
like that people were just like as a
cool story idea I wouldn't have done it
but that's a cool idea so I like that
series as well iron fist I liked more
than him but that was the first one that
felt like homework where it's like you
got to get to the end and just make it
to the end you got to be able to say who
completed it and there was a bit of that
with defenders of like well now I just
got to get to eight to finish this so
not it's not I know it doesn't sound
hopefully it doesn't sound like I'm
[ __ ] on it cuz I'm certainly not but
it was it's certainly not a rave it was
totally watchable and I'm glad it exists
and I hope they do it again and I hope
next time they do it they do something
that you know grabs my fancy a little
bit more but I was happy to watch the
whole thing I'm glad it exists you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's make it a regular thing man this
has been really [ __ ] fun give it up
for the guy over here without whom we
got no fat man I'm Batman mr. mark
Bernard and this dude right here
smiley Kevin Smith that is fat man I'm
Batman for this week tune in next week
same fat time same fat channels maka
more youtube.com/ says Kevin Smith I'm
still pointing at nothing - there's
nothing there gives a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you